I know who you are he didn't know dick
I never saw that [__] [__] before in
my life
I was at a at a [__] hotel in Miami
and some people said do you want to come
play basketball
Jose Canseco's having a party
and I went over there and he wasn't
there
some [__] dude
his friend had a party
a bunch of people that playing
basketball and I was there for maybe an
hour when I [__] left that was it
but it was funny that's how I started
torturing him I was at your house that
night till five in the morning remember
I remember
over by the beach remember that once I
was breaking this house down for him I
was get I was like Alfred [__]
Hitchcock
I couldn't get away with him and he
[__] kept looking at me and turning
away and I kept tormenting him and
tormenting him little by little at the
same time the audience people like get
to get him the [__] out of here
audience people are like [__] you can
say go [__] you
I'm right there in the middle of all
this you woke up
and like oh you go what's going on
they're like oh this [__] Mutt and he
heard it
he heard it the poor bastard that he is
he didn't he showed up with his daughter
with a mini skirt on
do you remember she had like a [__]
mini skirt and had to check with him
yeah and by this point people started to
throw little things at him
and finally security saw it and came and
pulled them up that's what saved by
people do you mean you no I was right he
would kill me he would beat the [__] out
of me he was right in front of me then I
put Eddie Bravo on him to torture him to
tell me he needed to learn Jiu Jitsu
don't be talking to me you need to talk
to him you want to fight people you need
to learn Jiu Jitsu now I had him all
[__] up
now I had them all he was in bankruptcy
court you know what I'm saying and then
I got my hands on him I was tormenting
him that poor bastard he had no idea
he had no idea he wrote that book he's
doing a little bit yeah that's it he's
due you got to do momentum you have to
torment him he sold his soul once you
sell your soul and the funny thing is
he's got like eight million people on
Twitter phone yeah like he's a walking
business and he's a [__] [__] yeah
man I mean hey you know what we all have
you know skeletons in our closet oh
please if you want to go ahead and you
know you want to sell your business do
you do it you don't throw everybody else
down with it you know what I mean no
he'll never work and he didn't like like
Sammy the book of Anna could come out
and he'll get a medal but this guy I
don't know he did something that people
really [__] got pissed off on him
about which is like [__] with baseball
yeah
just you know that's kind of man law you
know what I mean like you know you go
out a bunch of guys I don't give a [__]
you know everybody's on their own you
know one of my buddies his wife calls my
wife and goes hey did you know and then
my wife looks at me and goes do you know
I'm like I don't know anything
she knows I'm not gonna know what's the
motto of the show I don't know nothing I
don't know nothing I don't want to know
nothing I wasn't there I don't even know
what you're talking the person you got
to worry about his man I really don't
know what people people come up to me
and ask me questions what's this guy's
for I don't know what you're talking
about phone numbers I don't know yeah
right and they look at you all weird my
wife always goes how do you do that
I was raised in a home where they you
know
number one whatever happens in here
nobody knows [__] nothing
and you don't know nothing I remember
hanging out with kids maybe talking
about drugs or something
and I used to go to my mom's bar and I
see people smoke pot I can never ride on
I would never say anything about
marijuana you ever seen anybody smoking
pot me never
I don't know nothing
I grew up in a very different part of
the east coast and because like I grew
up in a town where
speaking of cigars I was at a cigar
place with my friends in high school
once after we turned 18. what happened a
mom drove by saw me and by the time I
got home my mom knew about it that you
were smoking cigars and what'd you do to
you no she didn't do anything but she
just she had that comment and I I got
mad I'm like why are people driving
around this town
like it's weird like you have a you have
a small town so in a way you have kind
of the same thing they just don't tell I
guess it's still gossipy I would have
imagined like North Bergen
well it's small but big and that you
know what kills me about where I'm from
it's that it's supposed to be like an
East Coast Town
but they're like [__] rednecks in the
way you know what I'm saying like you
know the mentality it was like very stay
in town and get a job and whatever so
not that they broke my balls growing up
and nothing you know
I'm just saying here play some music and
start this [__] off the right
way absolutely
kick that [__] horse Lee
kick it
kick it Lee
kick that [__] horse Fleet
Monday night
April 28th
you bad [__]
the day the devil was buried at Sea oh
[__]
oh [__]
I ain't gonna sit here
and tell you I did backflips with France
and you know me dog I tell you how it is
listen to this song this is a bad
[__] you understand me before
you put rip Twitter Prince on your
Twitter
put a purple shirt on and get your dick
sucked I'm saying [__] it there you go
prank meal [__] what it is
actually that I got to go to one of
those concerts before yeah [__] yeah
give us a couple years back my Wi-Fi
Pandora's got his tickets she's a big
fan
I like Prince you know but I wasn't you
know into it as a she wasn't and she
knew all the history Purple Rain whole
video and it's funny because you know
she's like you know as a sexy guy I'm
like really babe he's like five foot two
you know [__] 120 pounds soaking wet
you know what's this whole Sexy Thing
and we're sitting there and we're like
you know two rows back and all of a
sudden you know he's singing he's
dancing on stage all live band and like
you know he looks over and we make eye
contact for a second you know but I'm
like ah I get it
there's a I think I just uh I think I
crossed over to the side there for about
a Split Second
I was questioning my sexuality
I was like oh okay oh that's what you're
talking about he's Bad to the Bone rest
in peace man holy [__] [__] that's crazy
what's up Lisa yeah you're sitting there
on Mumble dumbled you're stuttering
through the [__] intro what happened
no it's the 7 25 I'm doing good did you
eat the [__] Cuba sandwich yet bro I
don't know the sandwiches for 40 [__]
minutes you understand me 40 [__]
minutes at Porto's it's never it is a
[__] nightmare you don't get to enjoy
one no I brought him a pastel the
guayama I don't [__] thank you Joe
that's good stuff matters flatbread
crush is awesome thank you [__] around
dog a little something for a little
energy for late night let's just stop
we're gonna walk our ride home yeah
listen on the way home you hook her
right over here okay you stay on the
street and you stay out all the way down
don't [__] make a move okay you have
a nice Starbucks like a professional but
again there's a Starbucks that's the
[__] that there's a 7-Eleven that's the
nicest drinks yeah [__] Starbucks you
want to be out at night yeah
black coffee yeah bold Brazilian bold
you [__] Starbucks
no no that [__] will [__] kill you
ever go to Miami International Airport
when you're flying yeah look at
Starbucks
because right now they have like a
Versailles or something it's like for
150 they give you the [__] super
duper cup did anybody that knows like if
you have a heart condition you break
that into Force
when you go to Miami like the old school
lunch when you're driving them whatever
the [__] it is and you see those corn
and bodegas and you see four Cubans five
Cubans and a woman talking pull up and
they have the cup and it's a 150 and
four people will put a shot down each
and toast and everything like and
they'll be sitting there all day doing
these [__] blasts smoking a cigar
drinking coffee by the time four o'clock
comes Lee the head's spinning do you
understand you had spinning you're in a
trance you're in a complete a coffee
with a [__] cigar all day is it like
a high oh my God it just takes you to a
different Zone God forbid you throw a
joint in there or one of those Cosby
people that's what I was telling you I
was there the last time when they're
coming out of Miami my wife's like I'm
gonna go for you know you know we're
getting through security so she's gonna
you know bottle of water grab a little
you know some you know snacks whatever
I'm like oh I'm gonna go get a coffee
real quick you know so the Versailles
right there I'll grab you a sandwich so
we're sitting there and um that's when I
was like oh man so that's why I told the
girl you know I'm like hey I'm gonna buy
three of them but I need you to pour
them all in one cup because my wife's
gonna tell me that if I drink too many
of these it's gonna hurt my heart so you
just hook it up don't put nothing on the
outside of the cup and screw me over
here you know because you know I'll walk
back over and she goes how many shots
and they're like I just won and then she
looks at the cup you know sees a three
written on it I'm like oh charging for
three but put in one cup
I was lit up on the plane oh my God
I look like they put the sugar already
in it yeah squash it in there yep you
grinding a little bit of milk and they
put like a little paste then they blast
the next time you go to Miami
International [__] around go up to the
cube and let the thing go listen give me
one sandwich for here
but give me three to go don't cook them
and she'll give them to you to go you
put them in your bed nobody knows
nothing
you take those [__] home the
next day you put those in the oven at
350 for about 20 wait till the bed wait
till that [__] gets Brown wait till you
smell something right before you down
9-1-1 you take that [__] brother bam
that's how you smuggle Cuban food out of
Miami you understand me like just like
that
Buffalo New York was great thank you for
coming to the [__] shows this week
and I had a good time Buffalo's an old
school
Blue Collar city they will stab you
there like you could tell it gets really
[__] cold people don't [__] around
ain't nobody gonna wrestle you that it's
a quick [__] hit in Buffalo there he
with a stick cold be [__] around huh
too cold to be [__] around you ain't
going down to no match there or nothing
like that maybe inside without doing
they will [__] stab you there but it
was fun helium is a great Club what's
going on Frank man
what's going on with you my man
everything all right yeah we're out you
know uh letting people know about our
phone booth fighting podcast Frank and I
are doing and you guys are at ebi last
night yeah phenomenal show man
unbelievable I'm so glad Eddie Bravo is
doing what he's doing with that show
bringing back uh Jiu Jitsu the way it
should be the way I started training it
looking for people you know to go for
submissions you know if it ain't gonna
break a bone or choke someone out why
are we bothering you know then it's a
game you know we're just playing grab
ass on the ground you know
he does it the right way motivating
people and people have tried to bring
that back you know Abu Dhabi had you
know no points for the first 10 minutes
or five minutes whatever to call out
points you know uh metamoras has been
trying to do it okay no points but then
guys still just stall because you get
situations where you get you know you
get a World Champ black belt Jiu Jitsu
like hey man if no one submits no one
they're gonna call it a draw you guys
you know they're decent but now they're
like oh man if I can go ahead and roll
with like a Roger Gracie or a you know
uh buchacha or you know Drysdale or
somebody of this high level they don't
tap me I could say I fought them to a
draw I'm like yeah you didn't fight him
to a draw you just you ran and I like
what Eddie's done with his show because
you only get paid if you submit people
so you see guys what I saw last night
was everybody was hunting the whole time
looking to take something home with them
you know take someone out they're making
stars in that thing too like Gary tonan
we just had him on our uh phone Boo
fighting podcast last week this guy like
I love the CBI stuff you know and and
when I heard that they were gonna start
going to fight pass you know which where
they are now I was more excited about
that than yeah
yeah because I've been burned out a
little bit on jiu jitsu's last couple
years you know just because all the
points and the way the guys now the
system they play and I say that all the
time I tell people like hey man you
still put the gee on I'm like the rule
system for training that style and going
there and doing tournaments doesn't
apply anymore to fighting it ain't like
it was when I trained in you know in
2000 when you you get a guy who's a
black male Jiu Jitsu if he told you he
was gonna go do a fight in MMA UFC Pride
whatever two or three fights in he was
dangerous you know already now you got
guys that can be world champions on the
point system and they have a gimmick at
how they they play and they win but then
it's like yeah but that ain't gonna work
in a real fight you know that it doesn't
work in MMA and it shows they're not
making the transition over you're not
seeing world champions in ibjj coming
over and making a huge impact in the MMA
world but if you've got guys like I mean
right now if you told me Gary tonan or
Eddie cummins or even that kid right now
uh Gordon Ryan if you told me he has a
fight like he's going to do well right
off the bat I have no doubt about it
unless you match him up with a killer in
the top three right now that guy's gonna
be a you know I wouldn't put one of my
guys against him he's you know that
guy's you know but the way they fight
and the way their their training system
set up now that's fighting that'll
immediately cross over to MMA that's
submissions they're going and everything
they're doing even to get a takedown
isn't just to score points but to get
into a position so I can get to your
neck get into a position where I can
take your arm that's what Jiu Jitsu was
for me at the beginning it's like man
you know like Elio said you know it's
like it's like having a gun with you at
all times I'm dangerous no matter what
in the shower out of the shower you know
you're a black belt in that style of Jiu
Jitsu submission styles of Jiu Jitsu
that's a weapon it's so Innovative too
like seeing Gary tone and go to seated
guard because he's got that crazy
leglock game and you in your mind
thinking oh [__] he just sat down this
is trouble for whoever's standing up you
know what I mean how counterintuitive is
that if you saw you saw two guys
fighting and one sits down how about the
fact that you're thinking holy [__] that
guy just sat down the guy that's
standing up is [__] fall out get out
of there and raise those ankles up and
push them now what was it free the first
martial art you joined was Kempo correct
yeah my dad uh when he first came to the
States you know his uh parents they uh
they first came to Miami went to San
Francisco but uh you know his you know
he's the first uh you know he learned
English throughout high school but uh uh
his parents aunts and uncles and my
grand you know grandparents they didn't
speak English so moving to Vegas was a
good opportunity to get work in the
casinos you work in the back of the
house you know Porter's housekeeping you
know uh my grandfather was a shoe Shiner
you know here you know in Vegas uh you
know through tips they could make a good
living you know and so uh they uh you
know signed him up to take a karate
lesson so he started karate and then
really he got into uh the Ed Parker
system of Kenpo Karate fell in love with
it then you know he's uh 20 years old 19
years old working at McDonald's you know
going to school uh Community you know uh
UNLV and um met my mom there she was
also you know uh
a senior in high school job for the
weekend you know so then uh they start
dating and then my dad being the kind of
guy he is you know then it's like hey
you know you know what we can do
together you know let's uh let's go
ahead and go down in the karate classes
so they start taking Kenpo together and
uh you know my mom's career got shut cut
short a little bit because she got
pregnant with me and then uh by the time
I came around my dad was a black belt
and I owned his own gyms in Vegas you
know so I was that little brat running
around you know Annoying the [__] out of
everybody until uh you know I got big
enough to jump on there and start
training with people you know
it's a great system you know as far as
uh
it really carried over and it's helped
me so much in my Minds especially like
you know if everybody watches how I do
submissions you know going from one to
the other and that combination of
flowing of movement that came from how
Kempo works as far as like I do this
then I go to this I go to this and one
movement flows into another and I work
off of what the other person's reactions
are so you don't have to seriously like
people sit there and go do you think
five moves ahead I'm like that's not
really the approach because if you're
sitting there thinking you're using the
part of your brain that's slow you know
I mean using like your superego you know
that that part of like I should be doing
this this you're doing that that's too
slow to be in the moment you know to be
in the hunt
um but it is is more like a feel it's
almost like when you go to shake
someone's hand you know everybody kind
of shakes hands a little bit different
but as you're going you can feel the
flow of the guy's energy and your body
has so many repetitions of knowing where
to go you go with it and that's where
training the martial arts comes and
Kenpo is very much that way too you know
I block the arm here you guy pulls back
I know where my flow where my Reed's
gonna go from there and when I started
learning Jitsu and that's why I picked
it up so fast I only started Jitsu when
I was 19. I walked into a gym I had
always seen hoist Gracie you know do
ufcs I you know my dad you know he told
me from you know day one when he first
watched the UFC so you got to learn how
to do this ground stuff man this is the
future that's you know that's that's
that's fighting dude I mean look at that
you know we were you know what would we
do if someone grabbed us and took us
down to the ground we'd be in trouble
right you know and so um uh so once I
had that mindset that was established in
Kenpo that very versatile mindset you
know there's an expression in Kenpo that
it's not the water in the vessel but the
vessel upon the Water meaning that you
know once you uh water can be
free-flowing if it's allowed to just
take the form of anything but if you
stagnate it and you're saying this is
how we're going to do something it has
to be done this way
then it creates form and has function
and it can be broken you know just like
a rock it's solid you know uh we're the
ocean beat up the ocean how do you ever
beat up the ocean but the ocean can
knock you on your body it could do a lot
of damage and so uh that mindset of
flowing and movement to movement I just
took right into me with Jiu Jitsu I'm
like you know now I'm like oh if I grab
the wrist and you pull I'm gonna go for
a triangle oh you're gonna push back in
I go for an arm bar if I go for the arm
bar now the human Plata opens up oh now
your ankle's open and then uh other
influences in my life you know like Dan
and asado we were talking about earlier
you know because you know obviously I'm
a fan of Bruce Lee everybody very few
guys that are martial artists I can say
aren't fans of Bruce Lee so when I read
his book and then I you know was exposed
to Dan and asado and then uh actually uh
it was a guy that one of my regrets in
life is I never got to meet him uh
Northern California a guy named uh Wally
J he did small circle Jiu Jitsu I got a
hold of his one of his vhs's and he
broke down submissions in a real quick
way and I think that's why like if you
watch my Pete Williams fight I kind of
pulled off a weird Mission and elbow
crank from the bottom that you know I've
seen before in Judo uh maneuvers you
know Jean LaBelle had a book out with
go-kart they did it standing and I was
able to do it from the ground but a lot
of it was attributed to a statement that
Wally Jay had said and having the Kenpo
mindset that hey if it works it works
you flow with it he said that hey a
submission takes three components it's
just leverage you know you need a you
need a fulcrum you need a base which
means whatever you're attacking on the
other side of that fulcrum has to be
stabilized and then you have to have a
lever and now you can make anything a
submission if you have that you know
component in mind so if I arm bar you my
legs wrap around and I pin you to the
mat right so now your body's the base it
can't move my hips become the fulcrum
and then your arm is the lever that's
how I actually even started like I think
I was one of the first people to
actually do it because not that I ever
invented a move I mean how does anybody
invent something you know things have
been done by everybody but uh when I
fought uh Tank Abbott uh for about a
year before that I would always hit him
with plot design guys and you know hit
the shoulder lock and yeah I get sweeps
out of it but I wouldn't finish a lot of
guys a lot of guys know how to roll and
fight out of it then I looked over and I
see people's foot I'm like hey your
foot's right there well now I have a
base because you're I have your shoulder
locked well I can create a fulcrum with
my wrist and if I just grab you of the
edge of your foot create a toe hole
because I watch a lot of like woman
asada you know uh out of Japan seeing
his submissions and the toe holding a
lot of Japanese are really good on the
foot locks so I just started flowing and
putting things together going hey man if
it's open I can rip it off you know just
as long as I adhere to these basic
principles now I can free my mind to go
upon any of them I don't have to be
stagnant to go well an arm bar you know
I sometimes I sit in the room and Jiu
Jitsu guys you know we'll talk about
techniques and they're like well you got
to put your foot here it has to be here
it's not right I'm all hey man it's like
handwriting we all know the same
alphabet but all our signatures look
different right because within the realm
of the principle avoid an A and A B and
A C looks like you put your own twist on
it and what fits for your body your
personality and your brain and and how
that works and so that's why I'm not a
big
stickler for technique has to be perfect
and that doesn't has application has to
be perfect timing has to be perfect but
as far as the structure of you know well
if it's not done this way it's wrong I'm
like Ah that's too much of a form that's
too much structure you know and within
that structure fighting is chaos you
want to hold that much structure in a
world of chaos a world of chaos and
you'll you'll uh you'll break
that's beautiful thing brother ah no
I've always been a big fan of Kenpo yeah
I love Kenpo flow and overwhelming your
opponent I was good friends with a guy
and he was a black belt under a guy here
in the Los Feliz
and it was pretty interesting we just
became friends and he started explaining
why his Kenpo was different than
everybody else is in town
and it all started when the guy died he
left the sun in charge
so the guy from Pasadena lost his mind
the guy that does all the videos and
[__] yeah just speaking what's his name
are you talking about Speakman yeah nice
guy I see him in Vegas I always see him
at the airport that's the weirdest thing
what brother he does the the Burbank
thing the Pasadena thing right he's up
in Pasadena
but they there's like three guys that
are like uh they're supposed to be the
John Gotti but they're not the John
Gotti at Kempo so Tracy Brothers right
so left a lot of holes right the Tracy
Brothers yeah so now what happened this
guy
in uh Los Feliz
was the guy who
his teacher went to jail for murder
David something right here in California
but he's the guy that learned the the
leg lock Maneuvers from from Ed Parker
Ed Parker they didn't have leg locks but
what do you call those things Frank man
when I go into you and my leg hits your
leg like a hip chin so it had all these
leg checks in this style okay so when
the father died some of the people took
that whole section out
but there's still a couple people in
kenbo you gotta hunt them down yeah I'm
interested now that kept all the leg
stuff so yeah because I have a few of
them and my dad taught me right like I
knew about the heel hook because we did
it off of a leg take now guy throws a
roundhouse we used to catch it and then
reap the leg you know on the bottom
someone mounts you you can push off or
pull guard you can reap the leg by
coming underneath the leg and come over
the top I learned that technique when I
was a kid but off of a kick guy kicks
and then also now I'm gonna throw my leg
over the top and sweep and reap your leg
down and then go for the uh the heel
hook we didn't apply it very well
because it was kind of taken out of
context but uh the basic it shows that
someone was doing it it just got
misunderstood was it got passed on it
was
and I went up there with the guy a
couple times it was very interesting so
not only would he attack your hands
but his first movement was his leg
against yours to distract you yeah
knocks you off balance so yeah he did
that with everything
and then we started looking into it and
it was the guy charges a buck and a half
a month for two classes a week because
nobody else not the guys in Marina del
Rey not the guys in Englewood not the
guy in Pasadena they took that style of
it out even he has he even had weird
forms like he had the books read I mean
this is crazy yeah so and Kimbo applies
really well to street fighting
altercations and people ask me well why
do you think you know even training Jiu
Jitsu with a ghee I think has more
street fighting applications and people
want to give her credit for right
because I tell people like hey you know
you know MMA is 100 Street Fighting like
not really you know is it close yeah but
it's still not like why I'm like well I
haven't gotten to a fight with anybody
that started 30 feet in front of me
every fight and altercation I got into
like when I worked in the clubs at the
Rhino I got into fights I was probably
about six inches away from the guy
before we started fighting you know so
the distance in the range was way
different and probably almost all the
fights anybody here has been in when's
the last time you got into a fight with
a guy from across the parking lot and
then you guys start walking towards each
other almost every fight I've been into
I'm able to grab the guy I mean we're
within inches of each other when the
altercation occurs so a lot of the Kenpo
and foot you know leg inside the knees
um you know the clinch work the
different hand trapping extremely
Optical towards being there sometimes
you don't see it as much in MMA because
guys were able to keep distance in and
out a little almost more of a long range
kickboxing you know type of uh stance
and and posture and distance in you know
tempo
Wing Chun that never really translated
much into MMA like it was like a lost
Soldier like it just and I love it I
love all those stuff you're starting to
see a lot of it come back though the
front kicks now John throws them Conor
McGregor throws it that way uh you see
you know even uh the kicks you know that
like the Machida and uh Anderson Silva
the snap kick with the ball well they've
taken pieces of stuff yeah that kind of
kick that came from I mean not that it
came from Kempo but Campbell does that
kick
I'm pointing out his name but it's like
it's Wonder Boy or yeah
exactly well he's got more of a
kickboxing Taekwondo bass okay right
yeah he's more of the spot okay what
your point is you know listen people
have said well Taekwondo is Impractical
in the UFC let me tell you something you
catch a [__] sleeping with one
of those spinning roundhouse kicks those
type one dope things not that you want
and throw them to your [__] leg falls
off Jesus [__] Christ if I know it's
common I'm talking about one every four
yeah you suck them in you've been doing
this since you're a [__] white Bell
now you're a black belt right I mean at
that at that level if you're gonna yeah
no matter what that always stays with
you yeah and then the training camp
you're like you know what let me work
this you I told you don't throw that
[__] let me just [__] with it no that's
one thing I'm glad about the coaches I
use now Angela Reyes right he uh you
know trained under uh uh Freddie Roach
uh Angela Anna houliton is a world
champion female boxer and um they came
from he owned a Kenpo School in San
Francisco you know in the Bay Area so
here he's a Kenpo black belt she goes
into amateur boxing becomes a world
champion female boxer and then now so
now we've implemented that back into our
style of fighting so when I train with
him you know it's funny I sit there and
you know when I first started training I
do a a front leg wheel kick right and I
train with a lot of Muay Thai guys you
know that was predominantly the Striking
art you know the dominated MMA and like
oh no don't do it that way it's wrong
and now it's funny because you know 10
years later I'm looking and now I'm able
to throw the kicks the way I remember
that I was taught to begin with you know
it's like hey no a kick doesn't have to
be a real heavy set down put your weight
behind it because now that we have
takedowns if it's predictable you can
put on your butt how good's a kick if
you can only land it once every five
minutes to someone's leg and then they
just shoot a double and hold you down
whereas you know a lot of the snapping
kicks the front kicks you know I think
right now Jon Jones is a great example
if somebody can use the kicks the kicks
he throws those aren't Muay Thai style
that's much more karate style speeding
fast and it hurts people and knocks them
around and it gets his feet back down to
the ground so he's dangerous again
because you know you're always taught
too I mean swine Kempo a lot of the
kicks are aimed for the body or to the
legs lower because you don't want to be
in a street fight and lift your leg up
keep it's not so much about how high you
kick but it's being on one foot was
never a good thing if you're close to a
guy it's like hey I've been on one foot
might be a dangerous uh recipe for uh
success here you know you might not want
to be on one leg while the other guy's
on two unless you make the most of that
movement you bring the foot up snap kick
the guy to the uh the solar plexus you
know you put your foot down now you go
into a hand combination that was a
successful maneuver you throw a real
heavy roundhouse you kick a guy in the
leg Yeah it hurts but all of a sudden he
has both his hands up you know you see a
lot of guys get caught knocked out that
way it was funny because what if here I
thought you were one of those Abu Dhabi
dudes I thought you had been involved in
Jiu Jitsu since you were 12 and you went
to Abu Dhabi yeah you lived in Brazil
and ran up hills and stuff the whole
thing
and you just told me you started
Jiu-Jitsu at 19. that's when you walked
into a [__] first time I put a key on
where was that
um there was a gym in Vegas it's called
modern martial arts the guy that I ran
the school was a black belt in a camp
Owasso he trained under a guy that
actually uh trained with the guy that
trained my father my father uh trained
under the Ed Parker system
uh the guy Gary Swann Stephen LaBounty
some of his lineage and then he directly
trained in Vegas under a guy named
Clifford McKinney and then there was a
guy named Eddie flash Newman that also
trained there at the gym so Philip
karpinski was a black belt under Eddie
flash Newman phenomenal athlete great
kickboxer you know from a Kenpo
background went into that world and so
uh he also because he saw the
limitations of just being a pure Striker
uh went out and trained in uh New York
trained under a henzo and Rodrigo and
Gracie and so he actually was a purple
belt under Rodrigo Gracie so that was my
first exposure to Jujitsu I remember I
walked in the gym 19 years old time I'm
a black built-in Kenpo big strong fast
athlete you know
um I had a state champion in wrestling
here in Nevada and uh winning those
little guy you know
140 pound blue belt I wish I could
remember his name and give him credit
but we go out there and you know I grab
them down I'm on top of them you know
rolling around him inside his guard you
know so I put my hands around his neck I
go ahead and do the uh you know what
does uh Rogan want to call it this great
joke you know so I'm like I got this guy
what's going on Boom also next thing I
know I'm about to pass out you know legs
go up around my neck you know and uh he
throws me into the first time I heard
the word triangle you know and passes me
out right they I get woken up and do
that again you know I remember I was so
excited when I left there with the idea
that submissions were so definitive
because you know I've been in fights
before and I've seen people there's some
guys out there I mean you see them in
the UFC's you know that you can hit him
with a baseball bat right and they ain't
going away so you can hit him with your
best Sunday punch some people are just
built they're not going down I don't
care how hard you hit them and you know
the other thing too that makes MMA a
little bit like I tell people
real street fighting is way more like
grappling than it is striking because
you know if you notice everybody has to
tape and wrap their hands you're not
throwing knockout punches on a regular
basis bare knuckle you know go out to
your local gym find any boxer who's
worth his weight and tell him to go
ahead and wail on the bag for a round
with no gloves and no hand wraps he'll
look at you like you're crazy human hand
26 bones I'm not slamming onto a bag let
alone punching someone in the face you
know the human skulls one of the hardest
areas of the body you punch that your
hand goes uh and so you you and you were
talking uh on our show about that being
kind of a misconcept popular
misconception that people see the old
days the bare knuckle days and they go
oh it was way more brutal back then but
you made the point that it was safer
safer like even right now if I said hey
you're going to punch me in the head
you're going to do a bare knuckle your
hand's going to take a lot worse beating
than my head is you might end up going
to the hospital when you're done you're
going to break metacarpals and uh your
hand might never be the same again guys
break their hands even when they're
taped let alone when their hands are are
bare so the head damage is a lot less
people don't tape our hands you know
boxers and MMA fighters our hands aren't
tapes we're not wearing gloves to
protect each other's heads anybody
thinks that's for the safety of the
fight no it's not that's where the
excitement of the fans now that a guy's
hands are taped he can knock people out
a lot better I remember my first fight
with Roberto travin in the UFC my first
two fights before that I'm a Kenpo guy
we don't wrap our hands you know even
when we go to tournaments you put your
hand in a pair of gloves
um you know you don't really throw hard
to the face you're so hard to the body
you know more of a street fighting
mentality it's like hey I might throw a
jab pop your nose water your eyes but if
I'm going to take you out it's going to
be the solar plexus hit you in the liver
I'm going to try to hurt your body
because it's softer and uh less
dangerous for my hand
I remember I'm in the back and uh the
UFC has the cutman go back out there and
uh Stitch you know it sits there and
starts wrapping my hands and so I
remember after I get my hands wrapped
I'm walking around and my dad's like you
know you know what's up I'm like oh my
God I could put my hand through a wall
right now like
wow like so this is what it's like to
get your hands taped like a fighter this
is dangerous yeah and all of a sudden I
went oh [__] and my dad goes what's
wrong I'm like the other guy's hands are
taped too hard
I better move my head
This is Gonna Hurt how old were you when
you walked into a UFC cage uh I just
turned 22. at that point you were purple
about Jiu Jitsu yeah Purple belt but
with [__] wrestling experience that
adds a lot yeah it helped out a lot I
mean I only wrestled two years in high
school I wish I would have wrestled more
I basically did it because of football
you know a big strong fast athlete and
you know they were like you know hey uh
at the time the idea was you know I
would take you know I would play
football and I go run track through
discus and uh you know around in a four
by one four by two team but uh you know
in the in the winter time you know I
would just go to the weight room you
know I like lifting weights and uh the
defensive coach uh for the football team
was also the head wrestling coach his
name was Russ Elite you know he got a
hold of me and said you know you're not
very good tackler you know you're fast
you're strong you run around you don't
wrap people up very well let's get you
on the wrestling mat and so I went out
there first seven matches to get my ass
kicked you know I'm just getting pinned
in 30 seconds know what's going on went
home cried about it and then just sat
there and like okay let me evaluate the
situation what am I doing what am I good
at what can I and I was like okay a
double leg take down broke it down I'm
gonna do this I don't know how to
wrestle on the mat as far as you know
controlling and tilts and you know
chopping jam and spiral rides these are
foreign to me and I'm catching up I've
only been wrestling for a month or two
so I started cutting guys loose I went
on to my junior year with the two months
of experience got third and uh uh uh
third and State uh Zone runner-up
in the next year it went like 44-1 you
know uh one state went to Nationals uh
they went two and two at Nationals the
Pittsburgh Press and so I picked it up
really well but not because I knew how
to wrestle really well I knew a few
wrestling techniques but because of my
Kenpo background and the martial arts
idea of knowing how to set people up
knowing Rhythm knowing about timing and
application so as more or less I had the
principles of combat down and that's the
same thing that happened when I started
learning Jiu Jitsu by the time I fought
Roberto travin my first fight in the UFC
I had two years of Jiu Jitsu experience
Roberto travin at the time was a
four-time world champion in the mundials
black belt by all accounts this guy's
gonna murder me you know what I mean
this guy has been doing Jiu Jitsu since
he was a baby and you know you know not
only am I fighting a Brazilian I'm
fighting a Brazilian World Champion
black belt and we went out there and I
ended up breaking his arm and about a
minute into the fight you know through a
combination he fell down I was able to
pass over his guard went straight to
mount he went to block the mount by
bringing his knees up but he put his arm
out and just my mindset of being free
and flowing boom snatched up to arm and
took it
that's crazy this man
I used to how long now you're a black
belt now yeah I got my black belt
actually uh uh probably about four years
into it uh I was 24 when they gave me my
black belt so it took four and a half
years for me to uh get a black belt in
Jiu Jitsu and uh I got it the same night
I won the heavyweight title uh from uh
uh Tim Sylvia you know so once you break
his arm you got a black yeah so why
don't you break somebody's arm you go
back to the school and you go it's over
yeah you got all these degrees
from the time I was uh you know almost a
blue belts you know uh I think maybe I
got my blue belt I was already a blue
belt under uh Philip karpinski and then
uh uh a guy named Ricardo Perez uh came
into town Brazilian guy who was a black
belt under Sergio Pena who uh uh they
have kind of a famous story that you
know he basically was beating Hicks and
Gracie in a Jitsu match down in Brazil
you know scoring a bunch of points on
him he had a real active style and then
you know the rumors are and I wasn't
there I've never seen a video but the
stories in the gym is that you know one
of The Graces go over there and the
power building office and goes off they
have to stop it it takes a little while
and lets Hixson recover and and get back
into it and then Hicks and being the
champ that he is you know they had about
a minute left in the match when they
restarted it again was able to get Mount
and you know extremely phenomenal amount
if anybody watches his fights and then
was able to get the choke you know with
the caller and so uh Sarah Japan you
know great tactician train still in in
Vegas Ricardo I think now he's in Ohio
or maybe a North Carolina last time I
checked in with him
but uh it was right after I fought uh
Tim Sylvia I'm sitting there you know I
won the heavyweight belt but you know
there's a little bit of uh you know like
you know did he tap he didn't tap was
his arm really broken we're sitting in
the back locker room and in fact at that
point I think Pat militich Tim Sylvia's
coach came in the back goes oh no just
attend and pop don't feel bad you know
what I mean you know so I'm like oh that
sucks I really didn't really win the
fight I really didn't break his arm you
know I'm like okay and so then uh my
coaches at the time said you know you
know with the the ceremony the Jiu Jitsu
guys have just kind of threw the belt at
me and go by the way you know now you're
a black belt you know and so that was uh
you know my uh my uh black belt ceremony
was backstage at the uh I think it was
MGM Grand after becoming the UFC
heavyweight champ that's what it took
for me to get my black belt
and so uh you know then though we go to
the press conference and before it gets
started uh you know Dana goes up there
at the uh the mic and says hey you know
everybody you know uh Tim's at the
hospital right now actually he's gonna
get ready to go through surgery they
have to put a plate in his arm it looks
like because uh you know his uh his
radius and his own is actually fractured
in three different places uh you know
congratulations to Herb Dean that was
actually a very good stoppage and then
it looked kind of funny because you know
my whole family there's you know 30 deep
over there uh you know start clapping
and cheering you know and so uh it's
because some of the people were like you
know that's pretty barbaric you guys are
cheering the guy got his arm broke and I
had to explain to a few people like nah
man my family's not cheering because it
broke his arm they're cheering because I
mean not even uh Bruce Buffer announced
me as the new heavyweight champ because
after that fight they thought it was a
wrong stoppage so you know they
announced me as the winner but if you go
back and watch that fight Bradford
didn't even announce me as a heavyweight
champ of the world I got the Belt being
wrapped around my waist because there
was so much confusion about whether it
was a good stoppage or not so to hear
that that his arm was indeed broken that
it was a good stoppage was Vindication
it was like confirmation that yes Frank
Mayer tonight won this fight
conclusively no doubt about it he's the
champ
[__] tremendous tremendous night it
was a good night and that's the first
hope you got right you got three hopes
of the [__] UFC right three what
hopes like you broke three bones or two
sets of Bones let's see I I know uh
Roberto travin's arm broke Tim Sylvia's
arm broke
and no Garrett no Garros aren't broke
yeah so you got Lurch with the heel hook
right yeah okay that was the hill which
was tremendous that's the see that's the
history
of Jiu Jitsu that's what I started
thinking about joining it when I saw
that was I said you know it's a strong
powerful guy karate
and uh you know you know the guy that
the 10 Planet guy Ronaldo laranja yeah
his father oh really was my first karate
teacher when we came from Cuba and I got
my purple green belt then I went to
Jersey and I was a karate guy and I
[__] tournaments and [__] I never
[__] dreamed of Jiu Jitsu like Jiu
Jitsu and savat were the things that
were there but who gave a [__] well I
mean when you talked about Brazilian
Arts uh people first started talking
about it I remember when I first even
saw hoist came out the fight right I
thought it was going to do capoeira you
know I'm like ah these guys are gonna do
those little like cartwheels and [__]
like you know is that I didn't even know
about that like I came from the Bruce
Lee era I was there I'm an old man I
can't even Bruce Lee died I saw his
shift you know I saw it Go Bruce Lee
though he was ahead of his curve man he
knew about grappling yeah if you watch
uh dragons the guy hits a crucifix yeah
even the kimpo gloves that he was using
there right it's called the Kempo gloves
right those were those actually might
even you know if they were a little
smaller actually I think or even
sometimes more advanced than the gloves
we use now because uh look how many
times fights get screwed up because guys
you know we post our hand out you know a
guy goes through a punch you know that's
a maneuver that's taught like hey you
post and uh create distance right but
only problem is guys do this and they
they poke guys in the eyes inadvertently
you know it's not on purpose but even in
training you know when we train I use a
lot of bad gloves for my MMA training
because they're small they're you know
you can wear a 10 ounce glove and but it
leaves my thumb free and I can grab so
we can grapple but the advantage it has
is it covers up the fingers because
training with MMA gloves even if you
make them really padded they're open
fingered and there's nothing worse I
mean hey man you only have two you know
you have one set of eyes right you don't
want them getting you know poked out
scratched and it's easy I mean guys you
know you get the retinas and you know
I've even you know in training had a
high FEMA a tear in my eye where it
filled up with blood just from an
inadvertent poke and so uh you know
Bruce Lee had the the gloves the
chemical gloves the fingers are closed
on them so you can't poke anybody in the
eyes and you can grip and grab and
that's because of his wing chunk
background training with uh Judo Jean
LaBelle he understood grappling training
with Dan and asado they understood that
you know that fighting had the four
different ranges you had the kicking
range punching range grappling range and
then the ground fight
even in his fight with uh uh when he
fought a Kareem Abdul-Jabbar in the uh
the Game of Death you know a movie a lot
of people haven't seen because you know
that's when he passed away filming it
but he at least filmed his scene of
going through the base of the temple or
the building the different layers of
martial arts the different levels of him
right yeah you know
what a phenomenal fight they had and
then then he fights the top layer top
level guy was Karina Abdul-Jabbar
basically it would be what if we give a
super athlete martial arts skills you
know basically it was the original Jon
Jones and so he goes out there and he
uses actually grappling throws him holds
him ahead and arms scarf hole trying to
put him in a head and arm choke and
choke him out and and using grappling
techniques realizing though I can't
strike with a guy that has two feet of
reach on me I have to make adjustments I
have to flow like I said be like water
you know and used his grappling and
doing that back there what late 60s
early 70s before anybody I mean man it's
still never caught on he was doing it
there and he was such an Innovative guy
but I mean heck we were what 93 guys
still weren't training ground until The
Graces came in and showed everybody what
they were doing
that was like uh I'm gonna talk about
Matt Sarah him saying that he used to
have to go from Long Island
to like Asbury Park New Jersey once a
week
but he trained for four hours and then
take the two-hour bus back because
that's how far it was to train that
wasn't Jiu Jitsu wasn't on every
neighborhood back then how it is now
it was very uh
it was very smart you know Brooklyn had
like a school or you know and then the
Gracie's like no the machados came out
here and we're down in South Beach or
not South Beach whatever they call that
down there
uh who the [__] knows Redondo Beach I'm
very sorry
but I thought you were always like a
lifelong Jiu Jitsu guy see you gotta
[__] read the wikipediately you know
what I'm saying yeah well and I have
just a real good uh my body being a
heavyweight my flexibility and my
emotion you know everybody you know even
a boxer everybody boxes but within box
and you have different styles of boxing
and MMA even though I know how to strike
I have knockouts on my record I'm taking
people down my strong suit would I just
have a just a love for is the submission
game I've just always felt that it was
the uh the best way and it's funny even
I I I I tell my kids that they were
talking they're like you know Dad why
are submissions more important than
strikes I'm like well you know I talk
about the gloves that you know street
fight you know it's hard to knock people
out without hurting your hands and also
you know civil lawsuits uh you know even
if you pass a criminal uh case look kind
of bad if you punch someone's face and
drop a couple levels on them where you
know chokes throws submissions
definitely can control somebody and hey
man you put a rear naked choke on
anybody I mean they call it Madeline for
a reason you kill a lion you know what I
mean take them out but uh I say hey just
look at nature you know I mean in nature
things that strike things that hit
things you know Ram up against them the
strikers they're the prey they're what
get hunted because they create Rome they
hit things you want to look at who the
Predators are who does the hunting
that's the Grapplers if you look at an
anaconda lions tigers bears you know uh
cougar jumps out of the tree they
grapple you they grab on they go for
your neck they go for the choke you know
basically you know using teeth in their
throat mouth but it's the same concept
of wrapping a person up and
incapacitating them and so that's the
effective way to take somebody out you
know that's the most hundred percent uh
you know there's guys out there like I
said you know hit them with a baseball
bat they're not going to go anywhere uh
I don't know anybody in the world
anybody wants to prove me wrong I'll
give them my whole bank account let me
slip in a rear naked choke and tell me
that you're not gonna go to sleep well I
know that you're a man of the iron I
know that you
uh
believe in carrying the peace from time
to time absolutely except for when I'm
here in California the laws here and I
love it too I can't carry a piece no
more
and I carried a piece for many years
when I was a young [__] [__] that I
got involved in a lot of bad things and
I gotta taste them
I never knew how important Jiu Jitsu was
until I walked into that gym the first
time and did my first hit this game
and realized I knew nothing about
nothing now
I know nothing about nothing because I'm
gonna tell you what I'm gonna tell you
what real life is for you [__]
that think it's about
watching a TV show and the whole [__]
thing I've seen people getting taken out
in two [__] minutes
but today's world
in today's world you want to get in and
out of there and I know with two guys I
know I'll bet my bank account
that make me kick a guy in the stomach
keep them off for three minutes and he's
already sized this guy up
his Kenpo background his fighting
background you already sized this guy up
you already know you got a single on
them through that [__] plate glass
window and you're gonna pull and rip his
[__] lung out through that glass the
Hindu is gonna drop this [__] jaw
behind account he's never seen them like
that
and this guy's gonna come back at you
with a punch and you're gonna single him
down get him and break his [__] arm
when it come over within seconds you're
gonna be in your car within that before
[__] whatever calls 9-1-1 you're in
your car and guns not even a camera call
you played
I know this for a fact because that's
how fast it goes down
and Jiu Jitsu when you're on your back
in today's world you're dead
you're deadly
what do you mean isn't on the back still
okay get that you walk out of 7-Eleven
there's a guy by that red box you go to
your car
he hits you in the head you go on your
back
that's it he can stick his dick in your
[__] mouth he could take your wallet
flip you over [__] you in the ass like
yeah it's all on fire you're deadly if
you're on your back
if you could get your back and regain
your breath
and at least grab the guy's [__] pant
leg
or if he comes on to attack you it comes
down to attack you when I hit my butt in
a fight if something happens and I sit
down I'm like you better leave now
because if you want to engage me and
come on top of me and actually happen to
me uh
I think the statue of limitations have
gone now so I'll give vague aspects of
the story
um but I got into a big S squab uh my
Coach Ricardo Perez we're at uh some
fights and uh he goes over there with a
Marcus Aurelius to calm some guys down
so I'm sitting there ringside and uh one
of the other guys and I got a weird
feeling we walked into there anyways we
walked in there Dan Lambert you know
brought his whole team in and we're
there with them and uh you know majority
of the guys they're all Brazilians right
so I remember we got a weird vibe right
off the bat because I walk into this uh
these fights I'm on the East Coast
and uh the announcers like you know hey
you know we're sponsor a bunch of guys
we need your support here you know you
know we got to really help kick these
Brazilians asses and I'm like hmm I
didn't sit right with me man these are
fights you know what I mean like man
versus man like I don't really like that
whole restart game USA
USA you know you know you know hey you
know you want to have you know love for
your your nationality you know I'm for
that too I was hey my father my family
you know uh sacrificed a lot to become
uh U.S citizens uh so my dad you know as
a republican you know loves being here
learned the language became a citizen so
I respect being an American it wasn't
just a Birthright for him he sacrificed
to be here and so um I hate when they
all do it not USA USA oh yeah like when
you go to Brazil in Brazil yeah
and I hate when somebody tags with it
sometimes I just see if I don't even
catch that yeah I don't even catch that
I don't want to catch that people want
to feel good about themselves somehow I
don't know this is the Brazilian animals
God damn it I thought [__] no why did
you gotta mention I thought he was born
yeah so anyway so a fight breaks out
right uh they already said that and so
you know there was a Brazilian fight in
an american guy and uh brazilian's
getting the better the fight and one of
the Americans is up screaming and
yelling and so uh uh
uh
the coaches are trying to shout
instructions so one of the American guys
there I'm assuming he's American he's
didn't like the Brazilian team grabs him
by the T-shirt Yanks him off the cage
get out of my way I can't I can't
[__] see what's going on so uh you
know uh our guys run over there and
Ricardo you know very level-headed guy
he's trying to talk the guy down he sits
him down all of a sudden punches start
getting thrown and a fight breaks out
right so I see my coach who I'm living
with at the time now I've moved in with
him that's so he was like you know he's
like basically I call him deal you know
that's like my uncle you know what I
mean so I run over there and I'm on the
outskirt of the uh um
uh cage and I'm looking down and my
coach just disappears Marcus disappears
there's a big fight and I just I can't
see him so I see the guy that's tussling
with my coach I just jump over the top
try to throw an elbow and strike I hit
dumb mistake because I end up on the
bottom immediately my feet never end up
touching the ground because I jump on a
pile of people boom I'm on the bottom
right so I'm sitting there and also now
I I bring my elbows to my knees and I
try to get like an egg and a ball
because I'm getting kicked on the bottom
I don't know what's going on the guy
that started the whole fight I just
remember you know it looks over and he
sees me right all of a sudden now he
goes and grabs me by the throat and I'm
like I can't in my brain I'm like what a
Christmas gift you just gave me your arm
you had me man I'm on the ground if you
just would disengage I can't get to you
I had to get back up so boom I slap an
arm bar on them uh that into that
altercation really quickly he uh ends up
having to be taken out and uh we end the
fight that way you know everybody's you
know brawl gets broken up cops come
everybody gets separated and uh that was
the end of it and uh ended up on the
ground but because he engaged my ability
to do Jiu Jitsu you know saved me from a
bad situation being on the bottom of a a
big uh Ballroom bra as you say and just
even if you
I got a Jujitsu for the health benefits
I just go for the health benefits like I
could care less if I become a flying
master I just love breathing on my back
and doing all these it's good for it
it's good for you Brian it's good for
your body and finally you know I was
going over here to vmac but they only I
can't go at night during night school so
I was going once a week so I finally I
went to Flappers one night and I saw
Alberto Queens I said you know what I
went home he has classes every day at
lunch time
seven days a week lunchtime classes
stealing you can hit three of those a
week I don't care how busy you are in
them
so I don't know this is January and I
just go in there to sweat
just guess what just that's good I'm
glad you do that too many guys I talked
to on the street that come up to me and
they're like man you know it's beautiful
about the Jiu jitsu martial arts but you
know I could never be a fighter I'm like
why why do you got to be a fighter okay
you know I mean that's like do you like
playing basketball yeah you're gonna be
in the NBA no so then don't play you you
can't go play basketball down to court
with your boys
that's stupid right that'd be a dumb
thing it's like well if you're not going
to be in the NBA why do you even try
playing basketball and I think the same
thing with fighting martial arts Jiu
Jitsu Kenpo all the different Arts you
know they have so much to give you and
it's such a journey and a lifestyle just
because you're not gonna be the one
percent of the guy the term professional
I mean Richard now blue belt Jiu Jitsu
trains
yeah he's like come over great you know
there's times I was watching techniques
one of his uh instructors was showing
him and I was watching whether it was
funny because we're at the gym I'm at
Robert drysdale's and my kids are
training now you know and I I let the
other people coach them because I'm
gonna still be dad not the coach I'm
thinking that's a better way not to
model the lines you know I'm a good
advisor they come and ask me you know
I'm in the backyard in the you know
grass you know showing my son I'll show
him a sidearm choke and you know hey
what are you having problem with you
know the spider guard the guys grab my
sleeves okay you know you're gonna step
to the side cross knee break it down so
I mean I I give tips and you know and
that type of stuff and a lot of
philosophy and thought processes but as
far as being the coach you know being
the hard ass that sits there and goes no
that's wrong like this like this I don't
want to step into that role and so uh
I'm watching my son train and my
daughter's in the other room in the
girls class and I look over and uh Bindy
Casimir he's over there training right
it drives us and he's over there
drilling his knee bars off of a back
step and the way he's setting it up was
beautiful you know the way he trapped
the ankle and stepped over and hooked it
I'm like man if you lock that up that
way that's pretty much a wrap you can't
defend so here I'm trying to my wife's
like are you watching like yeah I'm
watching our kid and like I'm drifting
over I'm like but that's beautiful look
at that over there look at that
technique over there so the point where
now Richard and I we have to do our show
later that night at a no regrets bar a
bar it's owned by uh uh Sean Lane a good
friend of my wife and I and uh you know
so as I was getting ready to start the
show we're clearing tables out of the
way I'm like okay let me go over this
real quick you know I just want to make
sure I hold on to what I saw showing it
to him sure enough we're there you know
and poor Richard you know my 200 you
know 80 pound ass is like sitting on his
chest trying to move his ankle you know
and then one of the bartenders comes out
is everything all right I'm like yeah
playing around you know he thinks
there's a fight out on the patio because
there's two guys drilling knee bars you
know he just looks Over the Bar and sees
it but you know like when you talk about
Joey you train in Jiu Jitsu and this is
the this is the security benefit that I
got from it at sticking with it long
enough to get a blue belt and everything
is it's kind of like Frank said when
people come up to him and go oh I'd love
to learn Jiu Jitsu but I could never be
a professional fighter to me there's a
security in having a basic understanding
of knowing how to handle yourself now if
I run into a black belt who wants to
pick a fight with me I might you know
maybe another blue film Jiu Jitsu you're
being anybody in a street fight I mean
unless they grab a rock hit you in the
head right you know what I mean if
you're a Blue Bell Jiu Jitsu and the
other guy doesn't know jiu jitsu 99 out
of 100 times you're winning that fight
after six months or after a year of Blue
Bell Jiu Jitsu you know why you keep
training Jiu Jitsu to beat other Jiu
Jitsu guys it ain't about beating a guy
doesn't know what he's doing about Jiu
Jitsu you know you already know how to
you know Hip Roll you already know how
to hip exit you know sweep you know
scissors sweep get on top mount them
choke them you know uh trust me at that
level you're not losing but then after
you get up to that level like right now
every technique that Richard knows he
knows every technique I've done you know
all the techniques I've done in fights
pretty much in the fights are all blue
belt purple belt level techniques beyond
that the combination the flows that's so
I can beat other black belts of Jiu
Jitsu that's why you keep training now
how do I beat that brown belt that's
over there you know that's why you have
to keep putting in time what are the
chances of me and that guy actually get
into a fight outside you know chances
you fighting two black belts meeting
each other up at the club and not
knowing each other and fighting each
other you know it's gonna get hidden by
lightning you know what I mean I think
of it like I think of it as sort of like
knowing how to basically handle a
firearm it doesn't mean I'm you know
maybe I stick with it long enough to
where I become an actual sniper but if
even if I don't just having a basic
understanding of how to handle that
weapon it you got it in your pocket I
think as an adult in this Society
especially for women I think it's a
disservice not to train and no
especially girls I tell people all the
time I'm like you know it was made for
you it was invented and you can just
catch it boom done you know I showed my
mom my wife knows the basic arm bars
especially from bottom you know you know
one of the first things I show her you
know like I'm like hey if I'm in your
guard between your legs I go to grab you
by the throat I'm grabbing your wrist
she knows how to flip her wrist hips
over and lock up and then I explain you
know and I've showed a couple of her
girlfriends to try to get him to want to
train it's like look man it's your hips
versus my arm I don't care if it's Brock
Lesnar you know what I mean you're not
out curling what a girl can leg press I
mean even the average little 120 pound
woman at the gym can put two plates on a
leg press and and easily throw it up for
reps right that's to kind of force their
hips can generate you know you're
telling me there's a guy out there that
can curl that much with ease there might
be a few of them out there in the world
doing the strong man competition but
again we're talking about like you know
what maybe 10 guys out of the 7 billion
people in the population that might be
able to curl against that that whole
leverage concept and then throwing a
choke on a guy stops the situation real
quick saves him a guy goes to take a
girl down gets in between her imagine
she knows how to throw rubber guard up
lock them down put him in a triangle put
them to sleep you know he's going to
wake up talking to the cops yeah that's
a definitely way to save him now her
practice in Striking I'm not against it
but a woman trying to be 120 pounds and
knock a guy out it's going to be hard
it's not gonna be easy you know what I
mean she's gonna have to be extremely
well trained spend a lot of hours
perfect her art you know you know Holly
Holmes yeah she's going to go ahead and
work her doing a stand-up fight you know
what I mean on hooligan yeah you want a
boxer on the street you're going to get
you know you're going to get worked you
know Miesha Tate but you get the average
blue belt purple belt girl I don't care
what the guy's size is if he doesn't
know what he's doing we've seen it
enough times you watch the guy NFL guy
wrestles 170 pound MMA fighter as long
as he's a blue belt in Jiu Jitsu at
least the little guy's gonna win he's
gonna choke him unconscious you're right
Joe I mean it's made for for women in
terms of protection because that same
thing with my girlfriend I sure she'd
never trained today and I showed her a
couple basic sweeps armbar triangle and
I said here's all you need to know I'm
on top of you like I said hands around
the throat now I'm on the bottom and
you're about to break my arm and some
Dirtbag who's trying to do some [__]
like that he's interested in praying on
the week that happens to him he's like
[__] this I'm moving on that's two of my
kids well you know the first thing I
show my good development information
right rear naked choke right you know
it's like hey if I get into a fight with
a bunch of guys and all of a sudden I'm
struggling with one or two of them if
one of my people my children or my
wife's behind you should they know how
to put a rear naked choke on I think
it's going to get passed out you're out
of it I've just made them a Lethal
Weapon you're focused on me you're in
trouble
idently
it's the halfway point of the show you
do a jumping jack you know what I'm
saying you eat a Cuban potato now it's
just Monday we just play this on Mondays
and [__]
I wanna be around beautiful
see I'm sadly I'm to the [__] Gazette
you understand me it's Monday get your
[__] to get well tomorrow you'll be
listening it's Tuesday
I hope you're still tuning in
Lee is done look at the moment of the
corner he doesn't know what to do with
his little [__] Suge Knight blue with
Hawaii shirt
I went to five better battle or
something
[Music]
look at this poor kid I gave some THC
stars at death today all right he's done
struggling huh I just didn't know okay I
have a good time
edible stuff's scary right no it's great
man I love it I like it way more I like
way more than smoking it lasts longer he
sees the devil twice a week with Uncle
Joey we go
I see you twice a week at night we go
deep what you doing your personal time
that's your own [__] thing you know
what I'm saying why are you bothering me
for let me get some shout outs and we'll
keep the show [__] going all right
Dominique Salas
John F Cleo we're doing a podcast next
week remind me ookie spooky Rick Kush
Molly Danny biancoola with the North
Birmingham report and my man Mikey Stein
over by the one by one by one podcast
and also my main man down there in
[__] Austin
Bobby
Lingus in Chicago you know what I'm
saying what are you looking at me all
weird for a week that's August most
[__] tremendous by the way
yeah now where do you get those uh this
one I just happened to grab on the
tobacco shops when we were here because
uh I went on a trip with the wife and
kids on vacation last week so I had a
bunch of uh cigars with me from my uh my
dad's uh his cousin down in Vegas uh don
Vicente right owns a shop right across
from uh uh uh the Pawn Stars uh right
there on North Las Vegas just north of
the stratosphere and so he hand rolls
you know Dominican uh you know uh see
you know Connecticut rapper is you know
knows how to roll cigar right so you
know it's fresh made right there so I
always just buy about you know 20 40 at
a time I go in there and go through them
but uh when I get out of town if I go
into a shop and I can look for one of my
favorite cigars trying to purchase as uh
put drones and my favorite is the the
1926 uh and so that's a it's a good
stick man it's awesome
at least you're real with this remember
like 15 years ago everybody started
smoking cigars and people Tapped Out
[__] quick yeah now they had the
cigar everybody was in the mafia
everybody was smoking women with smoking
cigars yeah my wife gets on me a little
bit because she thinks now you know I
mean obviously you know your wife always
looks out for your best interest you
know so I you know too much coffee you
know too much coffee and she's like hey
calm down let's you know too many days
in a row and she's like yeah it's not
good for your heart man you know relax
and it's a little too much caffeine and
same with cigars I've had a couple uh
times where you know I get into the
Habit where you know I'll be smoking a
cigar or two a day you know doing any
work around the house helping out with
the kids and stuff you know I throw a
cigar in the mouth and my little torch
keep it going you know and then you know
so that's when uh she's like hey you
know can we cut it down to the weekends
and stuff you know like you know I know
you're not inhaling it but you know it's
still mouth you know cancer whatever
cook you know just chill you know and
then I always talk about Don I'm like
yeah Vicente you know the guy smokes
like 20 cigars a day and he just went to
the doctor and you know his lungs are
fine you know all right you know
we all have to have some kind of thing
when you're Cuban it's in your [__]
DNA like yeah like when you Cuban listen
we [__] came up on an island like our
[__] relatives what an island did you
ever think about that like you would
think about it since I can't swim for
[__] you can't swim I'm gonna get your
[__] together
but it's so weird like like when I met
my uncle one time years ago and my
uncle's one of those bad news
[__] like every time I saw my
uncle after 84 it was always bad news I
took him out to langers like five years
ago like eight years ago maybe eight
years ago
2009 yeah and we're eating and he goes
you know about your grandfather just
like out of nowhere he goes it was kind
of like the Dodges or something he goes
do you know the story about your
grandfather I don't know he goes
he married his cousin
like we're [__] immigrant he goes did
you know that he goes I'm surprised you
[__] [__] you know we're eating
and he's telling me this [__] I'm like
my mother had mentioned them once yeah
but I mean back then
a little more common even in the states
I mean no no no no no you gotta imagine
listen listen your your mom was Cuban
and your dad was cute no no see my mom's
white okay so that's why you know right
so your dad's cute yeah my dad's from
Havana so your dad's moving so his dad's
moving so his dad's Savannah so his dad
for me now here's where he gets [__]
up for him man okay let me draw the
[__] design for you and go with the
pen because I don't want no
misunderstandings here okay you got
three routes this could have came okay
either
there's only three options to your
[__] family
if your father came from Cuba either
they came from Spain
bro
or some part of Africa yeah or there
were natives on a [__] Island that
Columbus didn't kill yeah there you go
through the survivors okay so the few
that [__] survived let's say well he
killed you know he killed mat that the
way you know not the way he killed that
Indian he killed them and all his people
but the [__] that survived were
all Spaniards in a way they all came
from Spain and they developed and then
they brought over the slaves over from
Africa then they came with friends let's
go and take you know to work the sugar
cane fields and that added a complete
Different Twist brought over that's why
we were talking about the Santeria you
know the Santeria and the whole [__]
thing and then the the uh you know it
just brought over the Spanish like Diaz
Diaz is some kind of way
they're these [__] people that talk
with like a lisp okay like they were
completely different than my world like
the white skin I have is Diaz I'm a
Valdez I'm [__] them Desert Rats
those are [__] Island Rats the Valdez
I just showed you the cousin wait do you
see his sister all right you know we
they're the national Cuban band my
mother's sister got raped at a party and
my mother killed the dude stabbed him in
the back while he was raping his sister
so my mom came to this country like in
50 [__] two when they didn't give a
[__] when you just came over come on
over and she ended up Batista was still
a piece of regime and then she went back
on an identity
that she borrowed from a friend but when
she came back into the states that
identity became her name okay so my mom
until she died had an alias those are
valdez's they're ratty people my uncle
this uncle died in London we haven't
talked for two years this is the second
time we didn't talk for 25 years the
first time we pulled guns on each other
on Vermont 1984. no [__] no [__] [__]
the valdez's don't [__] around and
they're jungle people right they're like
mixed with [__] African blood and God
knows what else now they're telling me
they're cousins what do I have I went on
that [__] website to see your
relatives yeah ain't nobody on there I
got nothing nothing I'm scared to order
the kids because God knows to 25 I might
find out something might not want to
want to know a little jealous of that
though that you still have some family
history because that's one thing though
when you know when Fidel took took over
you know my father's family they left
they had to leave everything you don't
they didn't get to even take birth
certificates you know high school
diploma nothing you know the clothes on
their back is what they got to come to
the states with so you know when I back
in May I got to go down Mount kikawa
worked out so we can go down to uh to
Cuba I went with Arthur Jones you know
Jon Jones is a big brother uh and
Rainier you know another guy is a first
generation uh uh U.S guy but he's Cuban
you know both parents from Miami and
actually his grandfather and father uh
from uh uh what's the little uh town
there uh Hershey Hershey Cuba and so uh
I went there trying to investigate my
ancestry because you know obviously my
mother's side being you know from the
States you know going back Generations I
have an idea of who they are where the
last name the maiden name comes from
within my father you know you know he
came over he was 11 years old his father
passed away when uh he was 19. there's a
lot of family history there's a lot of
relatives I have in Cuba that I have no
connection with so growing up and not
having that understanding of who my
father's side of the family is you know
that that that's just you know you know
I think people that you know people want
ancestry you want that connection with
your history to kind of know where you
come from so when I was down in Cuba we
were there for you know almost two weeks
you know I was down there going down to
my father's own house you know he gave
me addresses Maps I'm walking around
trying to talk to people like hey who
else has my last name you know who who
who's my family here give me some you
know I went down to the the cemetery you
know trying to just locate where you
know my grandmother was still uh you
know where she was put to rest at you
know trying to you know get a sense of
you know where I come from you know and
and a lot of that's lost and now you
know but due to Facebook now even when I
was down there there are one of my uh
dads would be a cousin share the same
great grandparents was able to reach out
on my Facebook and talk to me and I was
able to connect it with my father and
not my father you know can go down there
to Miami reunion so we can set things up
and start you know making reconnections
because you know a lot of it was lost
you know coming over here you know like
I said you know you know fiddle Castro
whatever I'm not going to get on a
political rant here you know but uh you
know a lot of people you know that came
over here a lot of Cubans just didn't
get to bring anything with them you know
and so maybe in the first generation
coming from that a lot of history like
you know you know a lot of people can go
where their parents or where their
grandparents were raised and get to see
things and have history you know uh when
Castro and those people you know made
that choice they had to come over here
with nothing that connection you know
was broken and a lot of things were lost
how come how come an envelope last name
is Mir
you know we tried to work that out it's
funny one misconception that I actually
got to correct was a lot of people
thought that because you know my name is
Francisco right from Francisco Santos
Mir III and uh they thought maybe uh
because I shortened my first name
Francisco to Frank but my dad does that
too you know Spanish is his first
language Jose is my first name yeah yeah
my name is Joey yeah that's it done
we're in the States you know what I mean
you go by Frank you know what I mean uh
and so I'll go by Frank so they thought
the same thing like oh look at this
white washed [__] you know Cuban he
doesn't want to acknowledge his family
I'm like what do you mean I want to
acknowledge my family I go by Frank you
know Francisco's my name I don't and I
go well your last name is Miranda you
shortened it I'm all no I didn't that's
the name I was born with what are you
talking about look at my brain so I even
went to my dad I'm like hey Pops
was our last name Miranda and we
shortened it he's all nah man our last
name is Mir and even when I went back to
Cuba actually one of the instructors
down there I was down there at MMA
tournament uh he says yeah one of his
students last name is Mir and possibly
cousins and trying to figure each other
out but that's because what you're
talking about our ancestry going back
several Generations but I don't have
connection to figure out how or who it
came from Spain through Morocco Morocco
has the last name here you know
Moroccans did a lot of uh you know
rubbing around and now here's the
problem then everybody that's [__]
says your last name says it wrong
because if they're from Morocco it's
move yeah right it's front view well you
know a funny story about the right my
dad pronounced the last name Mir right
right
and uh and for the longest time I'm a
kid you know you go to school I run for
a touchdown people go that's Frank Murr
so I used to go with it man you know I
mean I'm not gonna I'm that guy man I'm
easy going you know what I mean so after
a while man I just started introducing
myself people who are you Frank Murr I'm
not going to sit here and every time I
meet somebody
correct you on how to pronounce my last
name and then uh and then in the UFC I
think my very first fire Robert I even
pronounced it that way hey what's your
name Frank Murr and my dad even said he
goes hey you know son you kind of have
an opportunity now to kind of set the
record straight you know why don't you
just go and pronounce your your last
name the correct way I'm like oh yeah
you're right so Frank bear I'll go ahead
and I'll start doing that you know and
so uh yeah because you know you come
here I mean other cultures you probably
can relate they have a last name or a
name that you know when you say it in
English people have a harder time
pronouncing yeah you just go with it man
hey you know you mangled my name what is
it you know yeah that works works for me
man whatever you want to say can we get
the conversation going because I'm not
gonna sit here and spend three minutes
every time I meet somebody explaining
them that Cuba and this is how you say
the last name and no it's not shorting
for the Mercedes I said it me yeah
that's it and I can see it now now that
you said it that way I can see it yeah
yeah so it's not a very you know there
are people in Cuba last name here coming
from from Spain that's where the last
name came through when I found out you
were Cuban my head exploded
because I know you're a twin
I grew up with your twin no kidding I
swear to God we laugh all the time
and whenever you you fight he calls me
up my twins fighting we [__] giggle
on that's awesome his name is Carlos
Quintero okay and he's about 50 70s in
Jersey
stabbed a bunch of [__] great
guys humans and knives right him and his
brother I've known since day one you
know they were they they grew up in the
hard part of Jersey and they lived on
the bottom of the hills cars used to
always run and hit their house and it
was crazy but
uh first time I heard you talk I was
like Jesus Christ the Hammond Carlos
would drive each other crazy in a
[__] room all right we got to meet
each other man that'd be cool oh so we
always talk whenever you fight and stuff
so I
his younger brother Dee someone George
Elias do you remember George Elias used
to work for the UFC
yeah
I called them today to tell them you
were around but I couldn't get a hold of
him either three blocks away he was in
Studio City so he told me you were cute
my head almost exploded
yeah it's funny a lot of people know
you're dead a lot of people have said to
me they know he worked security with him
yeah his director security for uh
Station Casinos after I left Metro uh
you know Metro Police yeah it was
metropolis.com yeah uh Jesus Christ yeah
is that one of those hard Edge Cubans
yeah man and then uh then he got into
security work you know for the casinos
worked for the fertitas workstation
casinos now he's a director of security
uh wears a suit you know deals but my
dad's you know typical Cuban you know
great talker you know doesn't have to
worry about carrying a gun or anything
he can you know he defuses situations
and you know you walk in there with an
issue you walk back out just what
happened I remember Judo Minds yes the
accent yeah oh yeah real thick it's
funny
it's funny because I don't notice it
because that's what I grew up with in
fact sometimes when I do commentating
people be like you don't say that word
right I'm like ah you got to realize
that my English even though I don't
speak Spanish came from a guy that it
was his second language you know what I
mean in the household so sometimes I I
mispronounce words the wrong way you
know just not on purpose I try to go
back through and reevaluate and get it
the right way but uh you know you're
around that and you know his like I said
my dad's generation my his cousins
Miguel Delgado uh
Roberto you know they're all the first
generation you know they're all you know
uh full-blooded Cuban born in Cuba but
as far as speaking English they were the
first uh to to learn English they had to
go in there you know if my uh
grandfather or his grandfather you know
wanted to go buy a car aunt and uncles
my dad was the one had to go in there
and and translate and help figure it out
because of learning English you know
which you know it took a little while
and I think that's also too a bit of a
disservice my dad because of Spanish
holding back a lot of his family members
not be able to speak English that's why
he regrets it now but in the early 80s
he's like you know why am I going to
teach my kids Spanish and English you
know you know it's not going to help him
it's only going to hurt him you know
we're in America English is the language
that we need and he fought so hard to
learn how to speak English properly and
saw how you know family members that
didn't want to learn how to speak
English how they struggled you know so
he didn't look at that as an advantage
he sees that now as a mistake he's like
man I wish I would have passed that on
to you I apologize but at the time you
know that's what I thought was best for
you know and so uh I [__] hated it
yeah when I lived in New York City I
[__] hated it really when I first
moved to New York from Cuba
and she would call my name out of that
[__] window
I wouldn't answer really I wouldn't
answer don't [__] call me Jose
Antonio for those [__] kids
don't [__] talk to me in Spanish in
front of those [__] all right
and she would talk to me in Spanish and
I have to pull her aside don't talk to
me [__] Spanish and she's saying when
you're out there you talk English when
you're in here I talk to you whatever
the [__] I want to talk in Spanish
so I went on revolt and she said okay
you need sneakers next week right let's
see how you're gonna come ask me because
if you come ask me in English you're not
going to get those sneakers so get ready
for [__] Revolt you want to revolt
[__] so I hated it but I
adjusted it yeah let me tell you
something the day I was burying her in
that [__] hole I realized how lucky I
was nah she beat me up all those years
and then after she died I didn't speak
that type of spent see I speak a Cuban
that your dad would look at me and go
don't talk well you speak like probably
from a guy's from Miami you know I speak
like a guy from United City oh okay and
I grew up with teeth and then ask you
that what a thief that is that's what
they call like [__] Street merchants
in Cuba like she used to call me Cuban
there's a lot of slang though you know
right so we speak with a lot of slang
and a lot of people like I have I met a
guy in an audition one day and he was
like a real decent Cuban and I was doing
stand up and this [__] on the
way I wouldn't even shake my hand
like him and his wife
clipped up and walked past me there's
two types of humans bro there's Pasadena
Cubans
there's Cubans that know they got
African blood in them and there's Cubans
that don't want to hear that [__] you
know what I'm saying yeah and then the
Pasadena Cubans don't put Mumbo up in
front of those [__] don't run
out of that house yeah they're very
intelligent humans they have that
Spanish blood to them if you look at my
Uncle you could tell he plays basketball
some you know he got burnt with my
sister's darkest [__] which is funny
though right because this is dark as
[__] my cousin who you saw is light I'll
show you his sister I've seen a picture
uh she's dark my dad told me about my
great-grandmother you know African she's
out too yeah that's it that's just the
way it is and you accept it you go [__]
it you know I hope TMZ don't get a hold
of this but it don't matter you know it
don't matter Lisa yet look at the poor
kid
[Applause]
you know what I'm saying
who gives a [__] at this point in the
game I'm 53 I got one for the gray one
of banana peel what's up dog everything
all right here absolutely I've been
looking you know what I I gotta say man
I so much respect for what you guys do
here on the church or what's happening
now because uh you know you're in my my
regular podcast rotation and you know
Frank is because we started doing this
phone booth fighting podcast together uh
you know Frank's getting up to speed on
the world of podcasting but I told him I
I you know I asked him I said let's
let's go out to LA we knew we wanted
Eddie Bravo invited us out to ebi to do
our podcast I wish we did and I said
let's let's hit a couple of podcasts
while we're at it like the the top
podcasts you know and I appreciate I hit
you up and asked if we could come out
well I gotta tell you
my next question for Franklin what was
your next move but I don't have to tell
you what your next move Frank
you have the World by the balls right
now I think they did you a favor
I think they did your favor you're an
intelligent guy you still speak fluently
you [__] you know the game you've
been hit in the head with enough chairs
punches no no this guy you know that
this dumb nothing he got hit in the head
with chairs you ain't gonna come to him
and [__] him like you ain't going to
come to Frank mango why no you listen
come here for a second I worked the bar
in Vegas I got hit with bottles and
chairs and people you know are crazier
than you crazier than you then I went in
a [__] ring and I had a [__]
tackle you know Tim Sylvia and break his
arm and then I went there [__]
whatever Brazil and broke whatever
shoulder you know that's like tapping
out [__] Jesus Christ yeah I'm taking
out no Guerra that's like tapping up
Jesus Christ the Jujitsu world like
that's a sad day that is not jabbing
Muhammad Ali or knocking out my time
they close Pogo the Childs were closed
across the country the next bank and the
story it was it was horrible it was like
uh it was like Jiu Jitsu against Jiu
Jitsu and uh yeah and he's a great guy I
love that great guy you know
I know they got a trained in Cuba or his
brother yeah right bones yeah they go
down there with their Cuban boxing team
and it's funny because the first time I
saw them I was like those [__]
could pass as my cousins they have that
skin color that they can pass is my
cousin so I was looking at you though
you graded but you could talk that's it
you got to get the Gap you could talk
[__] to your 92 what happened UFC 142. I
strangled that [__] on Boom
it's 2 000. you are man you're a natural
yeah even when you announce sometimes
I'm like who the [__] is that yeah is
that [__] French man well I told
Frank when we started doing this because
I come from a radio background you know
and and we just much like this set up
we'd take gear over to Frank's house and
sit in his backyard once a week and we
do our show just like you and Lee talk
and I was like man you know I I I'll
give you a few little coaching tips here
and there from a radio background but
but you're a natural at it no he's he's
future it says yes he's the future
that's what they want somebody who's
natural
and who just talks yeah I've been there
I mean you know the guys sometimes when
they talk and they've been on the
outside of the cage and not that you
don't have to have been a fighter to
know about it you can break things down
you know I don't think Bill Belichick
said for throwing a touchdown pass but
he obviously knows how to coach a
football team but uh you know I think
there's a little bit more of a uh you
know people value that I come from
experience when I sit there and I talk
about what that fighter is going through
or what he's feeling you know what's
going on in that situation I've been
there you know I've had more fights
almost than anybody in the UFC how many
fights all together what about 26 or 27
yeah 27 fights yeah so I mean 27 times
I've walked down through those curtains
and walked out to an octagon you know so
when I sit there and try to talk to
people or convey what's going on I can
speak from a point of experience of
being there and then have you know
enough of a gift that I can uh try to
make it relatable you know sit there and
talk in terms that I'm not talking above
people or not trying to you know show
them you know the talk from a term that
only another 5 I don't understand
because why am I talking to Fighters
anyways you guys understand you know
what I mean I'm trying to uh when I
speak or if I break down fights I'm
trying to speak to not the guy who's a
fan who's sitting there watching the
fights you know I'm giving him
information he probably already knows
I'm trying to talk to his wife his
girlfriend his mother-in-law who's
sitting there in the room going why are
you watching this you know these two
guys are rolling around on the ground
listen to me talk let me explain to you
what's going on you know these two guys
you know they're throwing punches just
trying to throw Haymakers nah man this
guy's set throwing this move to get this
motion get this going these guys are
left foot you see his Left Foot Right
trying to gain this he's gonna do so the
other guy's not watching that left foot
that's real interesting when they hear
you guys say that stuff yeah it makes it
more interesting hey when you understand
something you always love it more you
know I always use the joke and well now
it won't work as well because I was down
in Australia I sat there and YouTube
because it was on TV all the time I
wanted to understand it but I used to
always make that joke rugby seems like a
real exciting sport right
I have a hard time watching it because I
don't know what the hell's going on I
could watch a football game because I
grew up in the states so I know what's
going on in a football game but if you
watch a sport no matter how great it is
if you don't really know what's going on
it's not as enjoyable you know it's like
yeah what are they doing they're all
just mashing up on top of each other
like ah no this is a scrum that's what
this guy's doing this guy's the hooker
he's sliding over the top this oh that's
so same thing with grappling I think
that's one thing about the MMA that
really you know it needed to convey over
there's so much complex martial arts
going on that uh you know boxing's
easier to understand obviously boxing is
really deep too it's its own science
you can break down the intricacies of
what guys are doing and Mayweather you
break it down especially I sit there and
I watch fights with Angelo he shows me
all right you know Arturo Gotti when
he's fighting uh Mayweather this was the
angle off the left foot setting up the
right hand of the body this is what's
going on like wow that's interesting but
you can still bring your mom your sister
your wife to a boxing match and they can
be excited because it's like well that
guy hit that guy in the face I get it
you know obviously it's a lot deeper
than that but even without a deeper
understanding it can still be enjoyable
but when you watch grappling you see two
guys on the ground moving around or two
guys in a clinch if you don't really
know what's going on you're like well
what's he doing he's just sitting on his
back I'm like no no you see how his
hand's pushing down on the guy's wrists
right now they're having a wrist fight
right now they're hand battling why are
they hand battling well because if that
guy's elbow slips down any lower he's
going to throw up a triangle now this
guy maybe now he's waiting for the
triangle and he's going to try to crush
past the guard on the other side oh
that's what's going on yeah they just
like they're sitting there I'm like well
yeah because you're not seeing the
intricacies of the little tiny fights
and battles that are going on and then
when I point them out to the people that
don't understand uh
you know that aspect of MMA then now I
think it turns over more fans makes it
more enjoyable they can understand and
see what's happening and now they can
see it from my eyes and see how why I
enjoy it so much and then it becomes fun
again it's like oh okay so I see the
battle that's going on because otherwise
you just see two guys maybe just laying
there another guy on top of another guy
what are they doing like oh this is what
they're doing I was just gonna say it's
funny you say that because at ebi
yesterday I don't even know if you
noticed this or not Frank when you
you've been to ebi Joey I mean your
podcast sponsors uh uh ebi but when uh
uh you know it's very quiet in there you
know when they're grappling and
everything and so we were sitting there
and we were taping we're doing a little
fight Companion podcast but I didn't
think in advance about how quiet it was
going to be in there so you know we're
kind of keeping like this and and at
first I thought boy I hope the people
around us you know are not uh bothered
by it but hearing Frank's commentary the
whole time and really enriching The
Experience like that I started looking
around and people were moving closer
because they wanted to be able to hear
it you know it made it that much more
enjoyable to hear him really breaking
down what they were seeing well this is
what I think happened
when the UFC went from pay-per-view to
Fox
you know I think they should have got a
more informative team you know Joe does
his best Joe's great at it right
sometimes Joe doesn't show I think that
when it's on Fox this is your chance to
suck people in if I go and I see a guy
again standing up against it listen
first time I turned UFC uh I saw a
[__] thank Abbott with that suit on
yeah and I turned it off but I never
watched it again I met Joe Rogan and he
talked to me about this [__] [__] UFC
[__] this is my grandma Bruce Lee [__]
I went to the Garden all those years to
see Aaron Banks karate tournament I saw
the guy catch the bullet to the glass
with the 22. okay okay I saw that
[__] four times you're gonna
show up with a bikini on like thank God
then I turned on again I saw the black
guy the guy that had the 18 black belts
okay
and I'm like are they [__] putting me
on I think you [__] people put me on
like jump I wouldn't even say nothing to
him then he started hanging out with
Eddie and they would talk and talk and
they'd do what you and the other [__]
dude did they'd be in the hotel lobby
you know sudden people's foot would come
off and they'd be choking each other in
the lobby and teaching each other moves
and Denny and Tate and there'd be nine
animals and I look at these guys and go
they [__] animals I came from a
karate background what do you want to
wrestle with meant for I never even
thought about it I'm like touching
people's feet that's the most disgusting
thing in the [__] world I'll suck my
wife's toe if I'm doing blah or
something like that but touching
somebody's feet you're touching them
you're talking about a Touhou before I
almost died over here I almost got an
anxiety attack that's a lot of people
still think that like oh you want to
fight Toe Hold you grab the guy's toe
I'm like no it's called The Toe Hold
because we grab that aspect the foot
there but no I'm breaking his ankle uh
it's an ankle break just the thought
yeah but people don't yeah they don't
grab in his foot oh absolutely and then
one night I'm going through this it's a
true story I'm going to the channels I
gotta join me my wife's cooking chicken
cutlets
and I see they're talking about it the
week before how Anderson Silva is
joining the UFC I'm like here we go some
[__] idiot with a bikini on I
gotta put on and watch Jesus Christ I
didn't know what to think and I'm
scrolling through the channel and it's
him against Chris lemon and I go here is
it I'm gonna watch this
my head almost blew up I got to see
Bruce Lee all over again here we go all
right now we're talking all right now
I'll start going to these [__] UFC's
and [__] it's funny to talk about guys
going on the ground you know half naked
you know obviously I've heard my uh
share of uh you know remarks made upon
it uh I remember one time you know I I
was a 21 you know I had my own apartment
living on my own now you know uh and my
mom came over and you know a typical kid
21 22 years old [__] apartment's a
mess you know so Mom comes over and does
what moms do puts a you know a pot of a
food on the uh stove starts cooking you
know and then as the food's cooking
she's going around apartment cleaning
and picking up you know and all I really
had at the time was a you know a TV you
know a 36 inch TV that I bought off of
my uh my uh first fight against Roberto
travin you know with the win money you
know and uh an Xbox and I had my uh you
know different DVDs uh on the floor
thrown around and one of them was a jiu
jitsu
I'm going to show two guys and they were
basically doing kind of like an open
guard work right but they're in you know
Valley Tudor shorts you know one guy's
on top of one guy you know he has wrist
control footing the bicep put on the hip
the other guy is trying to control his
knees and pass and that's the picture of
the cover and uh my mom reaches down
grabs the DVD you know to put it away
and then she glances at it my mom drops
it oh my God
and so I'm sitting there you know on the
couch being a lazy ass mom's cleaning
the apartment cooking food you know I
think I'm playing Halo and stuff and I
look up at her I'm like mama what's up
you know like and I'm looking down at
her like did you what'd you grab you
know what I mean like there's not no
pornos up in this place you know what I
mean I knew you were coming over at
least hit that [__] you know you know
respectable your mother you know and
also I look down and I'm looking at it
I'm looking at her and it took me a
second to catch up I'm like no Mom Mom
no these guys are fighting they're not
making love this isn't a homosexual
video this is uh this is Jiu Jitsu yeah
and my mom's like what I'm like yeah Mom
in the legs this and I was like ah you
know son you know and she has a karate
background I even tried to get her to
come to the gym and train a couple times
Jiu Jitsu you know after the first
couple days you know she came and she
goes you know son I'm sorry I can't sit
there and put a guy between my legs and
get on the ground and roll with him you
know you know it was awkward For Me
Maybe I'm too old for this [__] you know
what I mean like no but it's funny
that's first sponsor I still say I
remember the shock my mom had when she
saw that cover she here I'm thinking
she's like oh there goes any
grandchildren from this one you know
I actually have a little uh uh secret I
tell people whenever you're seeing a uh
you're watching an MMA fight that maybe
is not particularly exciting play this
little mind trick on yourself pick one
fighter okay and and convince yourself
that that guy is trying to blow the
other one okay the following the other
guy imagined that he is doing everything
within his power to fight that guy off
and if you get that narrative going in
your head turns into a whole different
fight what you're watching a little too
close to prison type of thing I don't
want to watch that stuff it's uh
no that's a great point you man
especially for when they went over the
fox they even tried to add that football
effect to it and I'm like oh
that's a growing period Oh my Jesus
[__] Christ that turned into
communist football on Sundays yeah I
think they definitely need it but now
now I start getting smoothing down and
explain to the people are catching up I
mean I mean you go to the fights now and
and a guy goes and starts grabbing
another guy's arm and pitting his hips
out the crowd starts because they know
oh it's an arm bar coming back in 2001
2002 and I'm in the UFC you would have a
guy throw another guy in a triangle
and and I I swear 90 of the crowd had no
idea what was going on you see people
tapping you know and guys started
looking around left and right they're
like that guy had his legs around his
neck why did he tap what happened you
know what's going on I'm like oh it's a
joke man but you know people didn't know
you know and uh even the announcers if
you remember things would happen
sometimes in those fights yeah yeah the
announcers would be like hold on a
second there was I think there was
confusion when there was a submission
trying to dissect what happened yeah and
that's why when we went to Fox I wish
there'd have been a little bit more
starting over again and breaking down
like okay this is the garden you know
maybe even having like you know a
section a 15-minute instruction okay
guys this is side control this is the
guard this is the Mount this is what we
can go red on road hit red on red on
round ball on YouTube
real quickly
wake up out of your [__] call Mom and
look at you you're out the lunch you're
over there falling asleep your eyes are
red
you look like you [__] when I was a
kid basketball came on CBS
this is 1977. everybody know who
basketball was you just watched Julia
serving for the last [__] 10 years
sizzle the ABA I mean who basketball was
but at that time they showed this every
[__] game how many games they show on
Sundays on the NBA too
sometimes [__] three they would show
all brand new
you know they don't want to do this no
more and I don't why don't do this for
each [__] fight
which uh video do you want to watch I
don't know
Pistol Pete Maravich how's that
he had everybody out there for years he
would do this stupid [__] that's it I'm
passing how's that
look at that passing for [__] retards
okay look look why this is called
passing the guard this is when
this is Pete Maravich
the greatest playmaker and passer in the
game today passing to Henry Bibby also
another [__] Savage
notice the fingers he breaks it down to
the [__] finger Frank man finger
spread follow through
just on a simple chess pass now Pete and
throwing that pass do you really think
about that when you do it or does it
become automatic well actually it
becomes automatic but three basic
ingredients in throwing any type of fast
is fingertip control backspin and follow
through all right now demonstrate the
other few fundamental passes all right
the four basic or the chest pass and the
chest bounce back well you can throw it
two ways either backs in or forward but
what is your major
when you throw that bounce pass isn't it
to get it right here try to get it right
to the man's waist where he can handle
it quite easily that's the key too many
people throw bounce passes that point B
you could kill this how basic is this
yeah but that's awesome this is half
guess what now if I was watching this
when the halftime breaks on and the
second period yeah I'm gonna be watching
for that now I'm gonna be like oh that
was a good pass that was a bad pass I
didn't play basketball I don't know that
but guess what I just now got more
informed and I'm going to be more
entertained and I'm knowing what I'm
looking at I'm watching for stuff I'm
more vested in what I'm seeing because I
have an understanding so they would show
this during NBA games
right on round ball I mean he taught
everything on there I you know I think
too from a commentary standpoint that's
why you know people don't give for
example uh Mike Goldberg enough enough
credit when they talk about the dynamic
between him and Joe because you got to
remember new viewers are coming to this
all the time and if it gets too advanced
yeah it's great for the people who've
been watching it for a long time but how
are you going to speak to the person
that's tuning in for the first time yeah
you have to speak it to the people you
need a you need a knowledgeable guy a
guy entertainment listen it's like the
Celtics they always had four black guys
and one white guy to tame him down you
know what I'm saying yeah
same thing on that note same [__]
thing you know you gotta have a guy
payment everybody down but you got to
have a knowledgeable guy explaining it
you got to have this you know how how
[__] much I would watch the UFC if at
the beginning they'd say in today's
edition we're gonna have Frank me and
teach you how to break a [__] arm
that happened you would come out with
your little [__] Geon and you break
somebody's arm next week George Saint
Pierre don't expect that'll hold me
there yeah how to pass the guard how to
an MMA that's for little kids that's for
everybody to learn Housewives
it's now it's knowledge is power Iacocca
Lee what is it well I liked uh Daniel
Cormier uh commentating the last fight
so look maybe they could have them
throughout the entire fight and like
commentate and then during the breaks or
something I don't know to teach a move
or
have one of the rooms in the back or
green room and sit there and go okay
what you just saw was this I can grab
you know me and Richard there I grab
Rich put him on the ground okay when the
guy passed over the top you know when uh
back in the Matt Hughes right all of a
sudden uh he uh he's fighting George St
Pierre in the first fight he arm bars
I'm off of a Kimura reversal right A lot
of people watching that I mean what did
I just see like well Matt Hughes was on
top he reached over for a
you know George reached over for Kimora
Matt Hughes stepped over the head to
block off the body transitioned across
the rib cage stepped down and it was
able to counter into an arm bar a lot of
people saw that like oh he won but I
don't think they really even got there's
a lot of people that watch that didn't
realize what the counter that they just
saw that a guy went for a Kimura and the
other guy stepped over the side control
and went for the armbar but having that
explain to people afterwards I think a
lot of people somebody like my mom would
be like oh wow that's awesome my wife
does it to me sometimes I can't even put
fights on at the house because she'll
sit down next to me no not so much so
you can sit there and explain to most
people what she's seeing but uh sit
there and um
understand it should be like Frank start
talking tell me what they're doing like
all right well they're the guys in half
guard but he's purposely not passing
because he's keeping control of his legs
and so that we can establish position on
top and this is what he's looking for
the other guy what does the other guy do
well you know right now he's trying to
get his knee back through or he's trying
to drive the other guy's knee up so he
can either work for a sweep or for a get
up and this is what this is the battle
that's occurring right there and then
she'll look back over it's two guys one
and a half guard one on top one on
bottom and now it's entertaining to her
again because now she understands oh
okay I see what this guy's objective is
and I see what that guy's objective is
and what they're battling for right now
and now I I'm back I'm interested in
again before I'm like if I'm just seeing
two guys do something what's the point
of watching if you don't even see what
you if you don't even know what you're
watching
that makes a lot more interesting
especially when it's such a growing
sport
you know when it's on NFL when I'm
paying 50 bucks I know what I'm [__]
getting
but when I'm watching it on NFL it's
because something I don't say no and I'm
sitting there and I'm [__] broke I
don't get paid till the 20th
then all of a sudden the UFC's got a
free show from six to eight my friend at
work won't shut the [__] up about this
my friend at work won't shut the [__] he
even got the shorts at work he won't
shut the [__] up so you watching it one
night you cook a steak and you're
sitting and watching
what happens if
a Grappler fights a striker he puts him
against the fence and they're sitting
there for two minutes and all of a
sudden the guy at home hears the booze
from the jerk offs in the audience that
don't really know what's going on that
right there I had it on for 10 minutes I
can't watch that [__] guy had him
against the [__] wall I didn't know
what was going on
you know they want kicks they want
punches they want French man breaking
[__] bones you know the highlights of
it that exciting part it's easy for
people to understand but then you get a
guy you know Daniel Cormier shoves a guy
Against the Cage I'm like well what
they're fighting for now is hip control
you know Daniel's trying to get that
left under hook underneath he's fighting
down the other guy realizes he's doing
it so he's trying to keep his rib cage
protected keep the elbow down and block
but now Daniel's throwing a punch up to
his head so now that guy now goes to
block the punch but now exposes his ribs
Daniel now is able to go ahead and lock
up the uh the underhook and now he
transitions off to his high crotch on
the other side on the left leg keeps his
ear posted in and then now he's going
for the back the guys fighting back but
now his weight comes up too high now he
dumps him and throws him over through
the air it's like oh that was what's
going on yeah I just thought I saw two
guys hugged up against the cage I'm like
no that's what was happening
what about money Mouse because like the
last previews to this fight his last two
fights he won but they weren't very
exciting so it was like the kind of card
we were kind of disappointed if you
bought them because they're expensive
they're 50 60 bucks but that's a lot of
money yeah that's sad because he has
pound for pound one of the best fighters
in the world and everything he does I
mean it's a science you're watching him
move he's up there you know uh you know
dominant Cruz up there with uh uh you
know uh um some of the great you know
Frankie Edgar you know some of the
greatest fighters in the world you know
sometimes the guys are watching them you
know they sit there and go ah that guy
Frankie's just dancing around I'm like
no he's not he's hitting angles he's
moving out he's trying to get you to put
your weight forward so you can hit off
the side he's gonna go for a strike if
you block and move your weight back too
much now you expose the leg he does that
post uh leg snatch where he grabs the
lead leg and shoves you down and then if
you go ahead and defend that after the
first time now he has you set up that
you're always see in that read that you
think that maybe a takedown's coming and
now when you go ahead and go there and
you step there and you get heavy on the
leg boom now he smashes down with a kick
all that off of different reads and
setups and what's going on like Oh I
thought I was just seeing a guy dancing
around I'm like no that's what's
happening you know you see uh you know
Dominic Cruz another one if you don't
know the science of what's going on you
sit there like I just see a guy with
like some crazy footwork moving around
I'm like no he's staying on a figure
eight he's moving on the outside of it
he's constantly out of his opponents uh
Power uh range and so now he's setting
up he's trying to get you to throw a
punch so you can be a little bit off
weight he's gonna have his feet set on
the outside or on the inside depends on
what 10 technique he employed when you
came in and now he has options a b and c
you know but if you don't see that you
just see a guy who's Bob in his head
moving around and throwing a punch I'm
like nah man there's so much science
going on that if you don't understand
what's going on it takes away from the
enjoyment so I'm bringing it back and
having that explained and broken down to
people man it's you know that's why I'm
so passionate you know that's why
anybody that actually understands what's
going on I've never met a person I
brought into a gym and started showing
them how submissions work how footwork
on their feet work how throwing a jab
isn't just your lead hand flying out you
know the intricacies behind pushing your
your hips pushing off the back leg well
why is that guy's jab better than that
guy well this guy is just stepped in and
kind of pulling his weight the other
guy's pushing off the back foot driving
turning his hips turning his shoulders
adding three or four inches to his uh
his uh reach putting leverage behind a
shot that's what he's doing with his job
the other guy now is cocking off the
side loading his rear leg looking for
the overhand shot always just swinging
Haymaker no he's not even Roy Nelson's
overhand right right there's science
behind it oh he's locking his feet
posting weight on the back leg and when
he throws the punch he's actually aiming
more for the back of the ear so he can
hit off your equilibrium and that way if
you pull away from it he still has a
chin shot you duck in you're gonna get
hit behind the head both are going to be
shots they're going to be pretty
detrimental but there's a science of
what he's setting up you know and so all
the fights they're that way they're not
just two guys just going at it you know
they're moving fast but when you break
down the science of what two guys are
going down and doing how do you not fall
in love with it I've never had anybody
that you get give me five minutes of
your time sit on a mat with me and let
me explain to you what's going on
you might not want to join up and join
the gym you might have injuries might
not have the time but you're going to
fall in love with the way I fell in love
with it the way we all here fall in love
with it just like you said you sit there
you first watch guys on the mat you're
like what are these two [__] guys
doing you know you sit there and hang
out with an Eddie Bravo a guy is a
genius of grappling on the ground he
starts why is that guy grabbing his foot
what the hell is he doing he's like oh
no this is rubber guard he's using that
as a handle you know he's pushing the
guy down pulsing through and now if you
don't keep your elbow down he's gonna
slide through you know a zombie rising
up grabbing an overhook now you're set
up for Numa Plata he can push it through
post up for a triangle go ahead and go
for a sweep or maybe he pulls up the
other foot and goes in for crackhead
control and really just weighs down on
the back of the head pulls down takes
wind from you setting up the next
position so now his hips are free to
flip over on the side and attack that
other arm man how do you not how do
people not get into that if you like
combat you like sports now you get an
understanding of what these guys are
doing everybody loves that I mean why do
you think football you name it Sports
people love to watch but people like to
understand it you know I mean look at
baseball we break that down in numbers
you know the different pitches guys are
explaining that people are knowing like
why is this guy doing this well you got
a guy on first so if this guy throws a
fastball even if the guy swings at it
you know he's gonna make sure that the
guy in first can't steal second he can't
throw a change up right now you know the
way the count is right now if he throws
a change up that Ball's gonna be going
too slow they can't send their guy from
first to second to steal because the
catcher is going to have now half a
second more to throw down a second and
get him out you know it's like whoa
that's what's going on yeah I just
thought it was a guy stealing the second
no man there is so much strategy going
on but people you know need to
understand what that is or it's not
exciting when that's the reward of any
fan investigating and educating
themselves about their passion like I
think that's why cooking shows are
popular you know if I make something for
you I give it to you you can tell me if
it tastes good or bad but if you
understand the culinary aspects of it
the ingredients that went into it you're
going to have a greater appreciation for
what what I put together for you that's
why I started trading Jiu Jitsu because
just working in MMA media I wanted to be
able to have a better comprehension of
what I was seeing to translate right
that's how it started I was going to
kickbox and I was like you know what
I've been doing this for 30 years a new
Jiu Jitsu school is opened over there
the first time I went in I thought my
head was going to explode like I had
them I thought I was really going to die
and then I would go over there like just
Jesus this is a [__] nightmare and
then I started understanding I go you
know what man the more I can really have
the stronger I'm gonna get I don't have
to be Johnny jiu jitsu you just keep
showing up here yeah and you're gonna
get a little every this is as tough
increments yes this is as tough as it
gets you know when you mix it up with
some kettlebells and you walk and you
lose weight and I love it I love it can
I announce what you you guys didn't [__]
no [__] no there's too many [__]
movements and [__] my mind don't catch
that stuff that quick that's why I say
that you're really [__] good at it
thanks because I tried to do it one time
I was like no this is I know a kick to
the head or points to the groin well if
you're training long enough you get it
too oh it is it takes reps you know I've
been in a gym for so many thousands of
hours that when I see a guy grab a wrist
and move there's only so many things and
most likely he's gonna do that are
highly effective so I can sit there and
that's why you know when I've
commentated WBC fights you know back in
the day when the WC was still uh people
loved it right but people [__] sit
there and go oh you know I remember one
time you know uh
I was sitting there going man are you is
this live is your calling moves out
before you see them like well no I just
I train long enough and I can speak fast
enough that I see what's about to happen
I can see the Ebbs and flows of what
each guy is going for I said oh here
comes the right hand
he got through a right hand how did you
know that was about to come I'm like oh
because two moves before the guy did
this I read what the guy did to counter
it I'm sure the other guy is a trained
martial artist read with the other guys
and do to counter it and now they're
playing the game back and forth it's
like you know they're trying to set each
other up and move
it's a good podcast though I'm happy you
came on no man I'm right too it's
awesome this is [__] I know you guys
again man don't mess down here in Vegas
do our podcast
you were training in Brazil yeah it was
a week you you were actually out and I
was down there in Brazil yeah yeah Sao
Paulo time let me get this [__] out of
the way we'll get you the hell out of
here you coming back to Vegas anytime
Joey anytime soon there July 9th I think
oh that's a international fight week
yeah I'm doing the whole thing for 200.
yeah Friday night I got to sit there and
watch on the stand-ups and uh when
hidden uh Rafters up top and got the
watch man great stuff man you both you
know you came out there I loved it man
and then Rogan came out there and just a
couple of weeks ago uh no it's been
probably about two years when I watched
one of his stand-ups to come out there I
was laughing because one of the things I
I completely related to I laughed my ass
off to the point where uh you know I
think some of the people were laughing
but I laughed like I mean the [__] you
know a couple guys around me are looking
over like was it that funny what he said
I'm like no you don't understand how
funny that is when uh you know you sit
there and he was talking about how you
know what is up with Fighters you know
when a fan goes up to a fight I want to
take a picture everybody wants to put
their hands up you know put the knuckles
you know and and uh he goes you sit
there you know you take a picture with
Tiger Woods you're not gonna sit there
and ask him hey can we can pretend I'm
doing a golf swing
it's crazy it really is yeah and I was
laughing because that happens all the
time I go and take pictures of people
they lift their hand up I'll lift my
hand up too you know you know whatever
the fan wants you know what I mean it's
their moment you know their picture you
know however they wanted to go but uh
you know the whole you know let's hold
up our fists you know what I mean
Buffalo some guy was driving me crazy I
almost [__] stabbed them
there's a line it's Friday night there's
another show
we take the picture there's no no I want
to take over my head in the apartment he
took it he looked at let me take another
one by the third one I go You Gotta Go
Dog yeah enough with the [__] Theory
you sell flowers for a living honestly
you won't put your [__] hand up leave
me the [__] yeah they want to square off
with you oh it [__] kills me anyway
why [__] around all right
listen we all read magazines we all uh
you know we try to keep up on magazines
but it's tough because you don't know
what you're looking for anymore
you know half the time uh
listen thanks to Pizza wall Benji thanks
to Netflix we're all binge watching but
now with texture you can start binge
reading trust me it's about to be a
thing when it comes to magazines you
know what you like and with texting you
can get all the magazines you want in
one super convenient place taxi has
completely reimagined magazines giving
you re-imaged sorry reimagine what am I
thinking we image
reimaged magazines giving you the
Articles and stories you really want all
in one place place interactive features
videos and recommendations just for you
the texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines anytime
anywhere using your smartphone or your
tablet your Breeze through the hundreds
of your favorite magazines including
back issues and they pick the articles
that interest you the most texture has
made it easy to find articles you care
about
listen I don't just read you follow me
uh uh what's that Rolling Stone I just
don't read you know ESPN magazines ESPN
magazine the text editorial team
recommends content for me every day plus
I can dive deeper into the personalized
collections sign up for texture right
now and get inside access to all the
content from the world's best
Publications especially if you travel
you want to be on top of this you can
download it all to your tablet or your
iPhone the best part is Texas offering
my listeners a free trial right now when
you go to texture.com Joey you'll gain
immediate entry into all the top
magazines including back issues and
bonus video content start binge reading
for free right now when you go to
texas.com Joey textit.com Joey the
texture app is entirely digital so it's
super environmentally friendly way to
consume the best magazines and articles
again
right now for free texture.com Joey
Frank man you should try this you fly
yeah I'm saying you wrote a lot man
you're a [__] Savage all right this
is uh this is a product here that I just
started seeing the commercials and I
went online and read and I dig it I I
love all this [__] because I like
sleeping I gotta sleep apnea I like
being comfortable some hotels I can't
[__] sleep you're unique you don't
walk like everybody you don't talk like
everybody you don't sleep like everybody
so why is every mattress the same
because custom mattresses will cost you
five to ten thousand bucks until now
introduces introducing healing sleep or
you can buy matches online customized
for you for hundreds of dollars instead
of thousands go to helix.com what is
Italy go go to helixsleep.com answer a
few simple questions based on four key
preferences and the result will be the
custom sleep profile used to build your
most comfortable mattress you'll ever
sleep on your mattress will arrive at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 100 free and for couples Helix
customizes each side of the matches
Helix customers report 30 Improvement in
overall sleep so you have a hundred
nights of trying out and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you 100 refund no questions asked
that's why everyone from GQ the Forbes
all talking about Helix sleep go to
helixsleep.com Joey and get 50 off 50
off your order that's helix
go to helix.com Joey and get 50 off your
order that's helix.com Joey j-o-e-y
Helix sleep.com slash Joey
I want to thank my main man Frank man
and Johnny [__] black over here who I
love to that's always [__] bringing
me him one you still talk to the porno
crazy guy he's in town oh Dennis off
he's in town oh yeah he's in town some
Japanese chicks asphalt him in the
Spider Run
fighting
new episodes every week
and read the Instagram deck oh yeah our
Instagram is at phone booth fighting
yeah websites phonebookfind.com new
episodes every week including as this
one air is a new one posted today you're
probably talking about all this all
right stay black Frank man who's better
than you nobody awesome thanks for
having us Joey we really appreciate it
man Lisa yeah What's your deal look at
you like [__] Zombieville I'm doing
good how many potato balls you're gonna
eat now I'm gonna take all of them oh
[__] yeah all right that's why I love
you none of these are vegetarian nah man
no I'm gonna get something I got a three
or four hour trip back to Vegas dinner I
love you guys we'll see you Wednesday
night stay black thank you for tuning in
to the church and what's happening now
yo don't forget I'm in Indianapolis this
weekend that's right Thursday Friday and
Saturday Indianapolis two weeks from now
I'm in [__] Sacramento at the punch
line
there you go if you are a girl who is
into do I do a podcast called math
therapy with two digit two girls
this is very fun and
put the music
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]